So Leute, ich bin am Start.
Und was habe ich da gerade im Chat gelesen?
Der, Moment, ich habe gar keinen Chat auf hier, bitte.
Der 16 Sterne Mario 64 Rekord wurde gerade geknackt.
Weiß jemand wo?
Das würde ich mir nämlich gleich mal gerne angucken.
Gucken wir mal.
Speedruns.
Zehntel, dass es in Asiate war.
Ich glaube, ganz wenige Asiaten sind da.
Na, wobei, ne, jedoch sind Japaner ganz schön viel am Start.
Aber insgesamt ist es bei den Speedruns gar nicht so verbreitet, wie man denkt.
16 Sterne.
Ah, doch, okay.
Das sind Japaner.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ne, vor acht Tagen kann ich sein.
Nicht der aktuelle.
Wer hat das eben geschrieben?
Ich habe es nur auf dem Tablet gesehen.
Ich muss nochmal schnell aufs Klo, bevor ich mit dem Stream anfange.
Und hatte nur das Tablet dabei.
Ähm, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wer es geschrieben hat.
Gucken wir mal.
Mario 64, 16 Star, WR.
Twitter.
Twitter ist da am besten für News.
Twitter kann man da immer ganz gut durchsuchen.
Save einfach nur nur in Backup-Folge.
Äh, ja, wo denn?
Hm.
Ja, gut.
Also, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Also, ich weiß nicht, wer das eben geschrieben hat.
Aber, ich weiß nicht, wer das geschrieben hat.
Aber, ich finde irgendwie...
Ah, hier, WR.
Sub, 15 Minutes, 16 Star.
Okay, wo denn? Wo denn?
Leute, lasst mich auch mal gucken.
Okay, okay, Leute. Wir müssen jetzt...
Wir müssen jetzt...
Twitchdetektiv.
Stonebanana... Wow, wow, wow, ist ja gut.
Stonebanana hat es geschrieben.
Ja, vielleicht weiß er auch noch, wer es hat.
Also, ähm...
Dann ist es Twitchdetektiv.
Ähm...
Also, äh...
Nee, Kategorie...
Kategorie... Nee, nicht live.
Einen Gott, warum ist das Marienfilms?
Hier.
Videos?
Weiß nicht.
Mit so vielen...
Nee, oder?
Nee, das ist irgendwas.
Clips, Clips, eine gute Idee.
Clips, eine gute Idee.
Was zum...
Warum ist das top viewed?
Wo irgendeiner Müsli futtert. Pogu! Hier!
Zwei... Zwei Stunden.
Two hours ago.
Was? First sub?
Under 15 minutes?
Na, dann kann es ja das hier nicht sein, oder?
What the fuck? Doch, das ist das.
Okay, das...
Das ist es wahrscheinlich.
Also, was die hier schreiben, ist natürlich kompletter Blödsinn.
Sub 15?
Ähm...
Sub 20? Hab ich gesagt? Ich hab gesagt 15.
Das ist ganz schön viel. Okay, gucken wir mal.
Wo geht's... Wo geht's los?
Das haben wir doch gut getroffen hier.
Das geht ja nicht lang. Das geht ja bloß 20 Minuten.
Warte, warte.
Ich hab mich verklickt.
Das ist irgendein Runversuch davor.
Okay, also wir sind hier bei
5.46.
Ach, die ingame time.
Das kann natürlich sein.
Also, 5.46.
Und dann gehen wir mal
20 Minuten zurück.
Das ist dann 5.26.
So, hier so.
Hier geht's los.
I was here.
Okay, das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken.
20 Minuten, eine Runde Speedrun.
Es steht noch gar nicht drinnen, ne?
Oder ist es
Virtual Console vielleicht?
Ne.
Ne, ne, ne.
Das ist Zero Star. Zero Star und One Star.
Das ist halt auch geklitscht
ohne Ende.
Stimmt, die müssen genau, die müssen das ja noch
überprüfen, ob das auch wirklich
legit ist und alles, ne? Ja, stimmt.
Stimmt, stimmt. So, Leute.
Ich muss meine VM noch anmachen, fällt mir gerade ein.
Damit ich die ganzen
Questions nicht verpasse.
Hätte ich vorher schon machen müssen.
So.
Eieiei.
Hier aus, an.
Ups. The fuck.
So, und jetzt müsste ich hier mein
PPGA Board am Start haben.
Räumen wir erst mal vom letzten Stream
aus auf.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was mir Vodafone
geschrieben hat gestern?
Ähm.
Wisst ihr, was mir Vodafone gestern geschrieben hat? Muss ich das mal vorlesen.
Und zwar, ich hatte Vodafone ja das hier
geschrieben.
Ich hatte Vodafone ja das hier geschrieben.
Ah, dafür, dass das Ganze schon behoben ist, hat gestern
13, also gestern oder vorgestern
8. hatte ich das Ding geschrieben.
Dafür, dass das 13.30 schon behoben ist, läuft's aber
wirklich gut. Direkt 45 Minuten Stream, wieder abgebrochen.
Aktuell läuft's. Er bleibt
bloß mit 2M mit Upload. Wie sieht's eigentlich aktuell aus?
Aktuell geht's, oder? Ja.
Ja, das ist,
das ist ja meistens auch nur abends.
Na, zumindest.
Hat Vodafone drauf geantwortet.
Ich lese euch das mal vor, weil das wieder so
eine typische, so eine typische Vodafone Antwort
ist. Ähm.
Genau. Ich soll Bescheid
sagen, wenn das Problem aktuell noch besteht.
War das erste, was sie
geschrieben haben. Was ja schon mal total merkwürdig
ist, da ich ja hier gesagt hab,
nach 45 Minuten
abgebrochen. Aktuell läuft's wieder, aber
nur mit 2M mit Upload. Also, das ist ja
eindeutig, ich hab schon oft das geschrieben, eindeutig
kein Problem, was 24-7
da ist, was aber alle 1-2
Stunden mal vorkommt.
So. Ähm. Und danach,
danach kam die beste, danach
kam die beste Antwort.
Bitte versuche als erstes einen Neustart
des Routers.
Oh, immer der gleiche
Scheiß.
Immer der gleiche
Scheiß, Alter.
Ne, ey.
Fax.
Die können ja auch nix machen. Ich mein, was soll, was soll
der Support, was soll der Support machen?
Was, was, was, was soll,
WTF?
Fuck. Was soll der
Supporter ja auch machen, ne? Also,
ich mein, die können ja schlecht ihre
Anbindung mal nebenbei einfach ausbauen.
So, so, so. Hallo, äh,
Dezix, wir brauchen noch 5 Stecker mehr.
Das ähm, war jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht
reicht. Aber das wird, das wird
ja wohl kaum, äh, in 2 Minuten
von irgendeinem Support-Mitarbeiter funktionieren.
Außerdem kostet das ja ordentlich Kohle.
Deswegen
schreiben die auch so nen Blödsinn.
Full Speed Gamecube
wie Dolphin Emulator iPad
Bro. Bro.
Nicht Pro, Bro. iPad Bro, Alter.
Der Eichler abonniert.
9 Monate. Huge.
Der Eichler, bist du da sicher, dass das
so ist, ja? Gibt's dazu offizielle
Studien. Ich glaub,
der Eichler, ich glaub das erst, wenn's da ein Video
von MyLab dazu gibt.
Sonst glaub ich das nicht.
Oh, ist ganz schön laut heute.
Warum ist es so laut? Ah, weil's 40 ist.
Deswegen stimmt meine
Audio-Geschichte hier auch
nicht. Deswegen spackt
meine... Mal gucken, ob Teams wieder den Sound
lauter gestellt hat. Das macht Teams ja gerne.
Ihr hört mich schon, oder?
Ah, okay.
Ähm, wo, wo
stellt man eigentlich... Jetzt Leute, mal Windows 10
Frage an die Experten.
Wo stell ich die Lautstärke
von meinem Mikrofon ein?
Ich weiß, dass es über das alte
Menü geht. Ich weiß, dass es über
das alte Menü geht. Wo mach ich
das offiziell in
Windows 10?
Wie geht das? Hier nicht.
Hier drüber?
Drüber auch nicht.
Wie geht das?
Ist doch lächerlich. Warum sieht man das nicht auf den ersten Blick?
Max ganz unten.
Was? Wo? Wo ganz unten?
Hier.
Device Properties ist wahrscheinlich das alte Menü.
Oh!
Nee, das ist das neue Menü.
Ah, excellent.
Was passiert eigentlich bei Test?
Test, Test, Test, Test.
Okay, was auch immer.
Ich hoffe, es geht noch.
Ja.
Ähm, ich mach's
immer hier drüber.
Ich mach's immer hier drüber.
Ach ja.
Das neue, also ich bin da
ein bisschen hin und her gerissen bei Windows 10.
Ich finde das neue
UI an sich gar nicht so schlecht.
Allerdings ist halt der Funktionsumfang
schlecht. Also was ich damit
meine ist, ich finde rein so die Technologie
von diesem Oberflächen
GUI Zeug hier ganz, ganz gut.
Dass das quasi so ein bisschen
responsive ist und dass sich das auch
ziemlich snappy und schnell und alles anfühlt.
Aber
was ich halt nicht mag ist, dass das keine, also das ist so gut
wie keine Optionen hat.
Und ich meine, wozu brauche ich System-Settings, wo die wichtigsten
Optionen fehlen?
Der Don Gaming, das habe ich
nie gemacht. Das wollte ich mal machen, ja.
Dass sie neue Systeme
und alte nebeneinander laufen lassen ist dämlich.
Ja, da gäbe ich dir recht. Ich meine, es bleibt ihnen ja
aber, aber eigentlich bleibt ihnen ja nichts anderes da übrig.
Solange das hier halt so wenig Optionen drin hat.
Ich meine, vielleicht will man ja mal
hier was umstellen, was
halt noch nicht im neuen drin ist.
Es ist halt übliche
Vira, Vira Windows Geschichte.
Ähm...
Ja, was auch immer.
So, was gucken wir denn zuerst?
What Battlefield 6 needs?
Ne, komm Leute, wir gucken als erstes mal...
Was ist das?
Warum habe ich ein Video über Akkuschrauber
drin?
Geil, wir gucken nachher ein Spielvideo
über Akkuschrauber.
Wir gucken erstmal ne Runde Battlefield Top Plays, das ist zum Einstieg
immer gut. Und danach gucken wir...
Oder ne, komm, wir fangen
mit dem... Mit was wollen wir anfangen?
Wollen wir den Mario 64
ähm...
World Record anfangen oder
ne Runde Battlefield gucken?
Warum benutzt du kein Linux?
Wieso ist doch hier... Hab ich doch Linux am Start.
Ähm...
Hast du deinen Rauchmelder smart gemacht, dass
die miteinander... Nein hab ich noch nicht, das ist noch was, was
ansteht. Also, wir gucken uns den
Mario 64 Weltrekord an jetzt.
Der ist erst vor ner halben Stunde
oder so aufgestellt worden.
Äh...
Okay. Wir müssen nochmal kurz
vorspulen, weil das gerade abgekackt ist, wie es aussieht.
What the fuck? Moment.
Okay, hier geht's los.
What the fuck? Kannst du den Anfang mal finden?
Anfang, please.
Ah, hier.
Okay, hier geht's los. Ähm...
Also, das ist erst vor
ein paar Minuten aufgestellt
worden, und zwar von... Ich weiß nicht,
wie man die ausspricht. Misskif.
Der ist auch gerade
noch on. Hat wahrscheinlich auch durch den World Record
gerade 13.000 Viewer, übelst
krasser Shit. Ähm...
Ist wohl auch ein sehr
bekannter Runner.
Ich muss sagen, ich hab noch nix von ihm geguckt.
Ähm...
Aber wie gesagt, nix von mir. Wir gucken uns das einfach
nur an. Ach so, stimmt.
Warum ist denn... Warum hatten sich das jetzt wieder resetet?
Was ist denn das für ein Kack?
Ach, hier geht's los.
Hier geht's los.
Okay, gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Du-du-du-du-du.
Wir kriegen da...
Wir kriegen da rein donatet.
Ist auch richtig so.
Der hat's verdient. Also wenn er sich da so reingehängt hat...
Soll ich's mit dem Chat lassen, oder nicht?
Soll ich mit dem Chat oder soll ich Vollbild machen?
Ich kann auch so machen.
Mit Chat.
Wobei, da haben wir Chat
über Chat. Das ist wir.
Gucken wir uns das lieber so an.
Ich find's ja geil.
Ich find's ja immer noch geil,
dass so viele Leute
ein Spiel spielen, was...
Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal nachgucken.
Mario 64 Release Date.
Ein Spiel spielen, was
vor 14 Jahren rausgekommen ist.
Ziemlich genau, vor 14 Jahren.
Das ist ja absolut Big Brain.
Ey, 24.
24 Jahre, Alter.
14 Jahre.
24 Jahre.
Kann man sich das vorstellen, ey?
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wo ich das
neu gekriegt hab.
Richtig Boomer.
Twitch Chat ist wieder am Spammen.
Das find ich ja auch immer übelst nice.
Ich glaube jeder, der das das erste Mal gesehen hat,
ich kann das jetzt nicht richtig zurückspulen,
weil ich da irgendwie übelst lang klingen muss.
Jeder, der das zum ersten Mal gesehen hat,
wird sich auch denken, fuck,
man kommt über die Brücke drüber,
ohne dass man, ähm...
ohne dass man mit Lakitu reden muss.
Was ist mit den Leuten los, ey?
Was macht eigentlich
der Zweite da im Hintergrund?
Außer...
Außer da sein.
Ja, ich hab auch mal
ein Mario 64 Speedrun Video gemacht,
mit dem Tylo zusammen, das weiß ich noch.
Der Twitch Chat, Alter,
ist wieder voll am Eskalieren da.
Das ist ja fast so schlimm wie im XQC Chat.
Auf dem DS...
Ich fand die DS-Variante nicht gut.
Mir hat die, mir hat die,
mir hat die Mario 64 auf dem DS
hat mir nicht gefallen.
Da hatten sie, da haben sie zu viel geaddet.
Never subbed, never donated,
Neighbors WiFi, Stone, Laptop.
Nö.
I genuinely never laughed.
Da hat er recht.
Der meiste, die meiste Twitch-Coffee-Pasta
ist auch richtig dumm.
Äh.
Boah.
Das ist übelst schwer, Leute.
Das ist übertrieben schwer.
Ich hab mir da mal ein Guide zu angeguckt.
Normalerweise, wer das Spiel noch kennt,
normalerweise muss der mit der Kanone
hier oben die Ecke absprengen.
Ähm, das ist übelst schwer,
aber man muss aus dem richtigen Winkel
an der richtigen Stelle runterfallen,
dann renkt halt das Spiel und man fällt irgendwie durch den Stern durch.
Total weird. Ich hab mir mal ein Guide angesehen.
Das kriegt man irgendwie selbst geübt
irgendwie nur zwei von zehn Mal hin oder so.
Omega lol.
See chat,
I just did a five head move.
I just pretended that I hated it so much
that now you guys are gonna donate it more
so that way you guys now think it's funny
instead of thinking it's annoying.
Thus saving the stream.
Foggers.
Hey Miz, are you proud of me?
Yeah, you're getting head.
Why would you be proud of me for that?
What?
Chat, who got head today?
What the fuck?
Sag mal,
sind wir wirklich
sicher, dass wir das Richtige angucken?
Weil,
weil ich sehe ihn hier
nirgendswo in den
in der Topliste drin.
Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung,
ob wir uns wirklich
den neuen Weltrekord gerade angucken?
Egal.
Weil das hier ist 15 und das andere ist 20.
Ich glaube, wir gucken uns
nicht das Richtige an gerade.
Irgendjemand hat auch geschrieben,
ich glaube, wir gucken uns nicht das Richtige an.
Ich glaube, wir gucken uns nicht das Richtige an.
Irgendjemand hat auch geschrieben,
vor zehn Minuten ist er,
das ist glaube ich nicht das Richtige.
Sub20, das ist der,
der macht nur seinen, seinen
PB.
Clips, nein, nicht Clips.
Genau, der hat auch 20 Minuten gebraucht.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist nicht das Richtige,
was wir gucken.
Vielleicht hat mich auch einfach der Chat gerade
gebetet.
Vielleicht hat mich auch der Chat gebetet.
So, da müssen wir das woanders rauskriegen.
Nein, nein, nein, kein Krach machen.
Browse, Clips.
Okay.
Das kann er nicht.
World First
Moment, die gucken,
wie was geguckt wird.
Die gucken, wie was geguckt wird.
Okay, was gucken die dann?
Ah, hier.
Ah, hier, das ist irgendein Livestream aus Japan.
Ach, jetzt kapiere ich das Ganze.
Ah.
Excellent.
Oh, der Knärbär hat hier, hat es am Start.
Ja, wir gucken uns das Original an, natürlich.
Ah, yes, excellent.
Jetzt ergibt das Sinn.
Wow.
Alter, wie das wieder absch...
Wir müssen mal kurz an den Start zurück.
Sag mal, ist das eine Herzfrequenz?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist eine Herzfrequenz vom Runner?
Das ist ja auch mal neu.
Reddit-Post. Ja, danke, Knärbär.
Excellent, fine.
Eine Herzfrequenz vom Runner.
Erstmal, erstmal
Ein Puls von 69, okay.
Der ist schon mal sehr entspannt.
Das ist ziemlich wenig.
Na, wobei.
69, 70, glaube ich, normal.
Also, Michael, ich glaube nicht, dass du 120 hast beim Sitzen.
Ich habe mal gelesen, dass ein Profi
Fahrradfahrer hat, also so ein Profi
Radsportler kann teilweise bis zu 40 haben.
60 bis 80, ja, glaube auch.
So, guck mal hier, jetzt gibt er alles.
Am Input-Spam.
Alter, dieses rumgeklitscht.
Ich finde es jedes Mal geil.
Wow.
Reset.
Also, ich glaube,
was er an der Stelle probiert hat.
Ich habe ja auch schon ein paar Speedruns geguckt.
Der wollte, glaube ich,
in das Bowser-Level reinklitschen.
In das erste Bowser-Level.
Und,
wo ich mich noch beim Tyler dran erinnern kann,
was er erzählt hat, ist, dass einem dieses
Intro, wo Peach den Brief
vorliest, oder nur im Englischen, im Japanischen
liest sie den Brief ja nicht vor,
dass einem das am meisten auf den Sack geht.
Weil man sich das
jedes Mal angucken muss.
So, das müsste jetzt Teuren sein, hier.
Teuren.
Falls man das überhaupt noch sagt.
Das ist in Japan
normal mit der Herzfrequenz.
Warum sollten Japaner denn
unterschiedlichen Ruhepuls haben?
Da stellt er und sagt, er hat
einen Ruhepuls von 120 im Krankenhaus.
Ja gut, wahrscheinlich, weil du nicht ohne Grund
im Krankenhaus warst, ne?
So, erstmal dran vorbei gejumpt.
Ach, du meintest, dass viele
in Japan den Puls zeigen.
Okay.
Ja, die Japaner haben da unterschiedliche Vorlieben.
Das habe ich auch schon gemerkt.
So, ich glaube, jetzt versucht er
ins erste Bowser-Level reinzuklitschen.
Was auch wohl funktioniert?
Warum man damit anfängt,
weiß ich gar nicht so genau.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, warum man
damit anfängt, anstatt die normalen
Äh, anstatt die Normen.
Na gut, wahrscheinlich, weil man sich eh durchklitschen muss,
weil es schneller ist.
Und man am besten vom Start direkt da reinkommt.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, wie
vorsichtig man damals
durch die Level hier gestelzt ist, so nach dem Motto
Mario konnte sogar krabbeln in dem
Game und keiner, ich bin da sogar
langgekrochen.
Und zack.
Macht er jetzt Bowser noch? Ja, ne?
Oder? Wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ja, macht er noch.
Plantera sagt, er hat einen Ruhepuls von 35.
Bist du Profi-Radsportler?
Und bam.
Ja, die ersten zwei sind easy.
Die habe ich damals auch immer First-Try
geschafft, das ist ja auch kein Problem.
Ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass Mario
in der japanischen Version einen Stern zeigt
und in der deutschen
Version einen Schlüssel?
Erstmal Rage-Quit.
Ne, nicht wirklich Rage-Quit, absichtlich Quit.
Ah!
Ich glaube, jetzt kapiere ich es, warum er das
erst macht mit dem Bowser-Level.
Wahrscheinlich ist es, aus dem Eingang da hinzukommen
am schnellsten und die nächsten
Sterne brauchst du mindestens
einen Stern dafür, um
reinzukommen. Das heißt, du musst das Bowser-Level
eh machen, dass du in den ersten Stock
kommst.
Und die Sterne sind wahrscheinlich einfach schneller
als noch hier Bomb-Omb-Battlefield
zu machen. Oder wie auch immer
die erste Map heißt.
Ah!
Das reim ich mir gerade zusammen.
Ich habe mich schon lange nicht mit Mario 64 Speedruns
beschäftigt.
Zumindest das Spiel macht heute immer noch Bock.
Und vor allem, wenn man sich anguckt,
wie easy die Sachen eigentlich sind.
Wie easy das eigentlich ist, ne?
Also wie es aussieht.
Also wie es nicht ist, aber wie es aussieht.
Und man selbst
hat sich damals übelst
abgebrochen, teilweise.
Ich meine, auf dem
Niveau, wie der macht, ist das garantiert nicht einfach.
Krass.
Das, ähm...
Das ist jetzt wohl
noch eine relativ normale Route, denke ich mal.
Weil, das habe ich schon vor ein paar Jahren
gesehen, diese Sterne in der
Variante. Wobei man halt
sagen muss, dass...
Also ich denke zumindest, dass es gerade
bei 16 Sternen halt extrem auf
die Ausführung von den einzelnen
Sachen ankommt.
Übrigens, ich habe Mist erzählt. Man braucht den Schlüssel nicht,
dass man in den ersten Stock kommt. Ist ja Schwachsinn.
Man braucht natürlich den Schlüssel, dass man ins Erdgeschoss kommt.
Welches macht der?
Ja, das ist dieser Sand-Dings, Pyramiden-Stelz.
Mal gucken, welches er macht.
Die meisten springen links dann irgendwie
über zur Pyramide rüber, ne?
Genau.
Und jetzt oben den...
Ja, ja.
Ach nee, der klitscht sich rein in die Pyramide.
Und man kann direkt oben rausspringen.
Easy. Hätte ich das damals gewusst.
Es ist super gealtert, das stimmt.
Das ist wirklich gut gealtert.
Das sieht schlecht genug aus,
dass es gut altert.
Ich hoffe, man versteht, wie ich das meine.
Sachen wie Half-Life 1, die vielleicht besser ausgesehen haben,
sind schlechter gealtert, weil die halt
näher dran versucht haben, realistisch zu sein.
Mario 64 ist deswegen ganz gut
gealtert, einfach weil es nicht gut genug aussieht.
Und
wahrscheinlich kann ich das gar nicht richtig
schätzen, was er hier macht, aber es sieht alles
äußerst flüssig und clean aus.
Also, der hat da
hunderte Stunden, wenn nicht
tausende Stunden Übung drin.
So, jetzt kommt oben das...
Also, man hört hier ab und zu
von ihm was klicken.
Das heißt, er hat den Sound an, aber er ist so
big brain
ingame, der sagt nichts.
1,1900 Stunden.
Ja, krass.
Das ist...
Das kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das war auch für Noobs wie mich
easy, das Bowser-Rätsel-Puzzle.
Das war auch für Noobs wie mich easy, das Bowser-Rätsel-Puzzle.
So, welcher kommt denn jetzt?
Der Bully kommt jetzt, oder? Kommt jetzt
der Bully? Ne, kommt nicht
der Bully. Jetzt kommt dieses Ding.
Dieses Balancieren, wo man normalerweise auf dem
Holzstück balancieren muss.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob man in der
Route noch die Bullys macht.
Da sind jetzt
schon neun Sterne.
Man braucht...
Man braucht doch sogar 16, ne?
16 braucht man für...
braucht man im Keller.
Und durch die restlichen Sachen klitscht man sich dann durch.
Durch die Tür klitscht man sich durch.
Durch die Tür klitscht man sich durch später.
Und durch die Treppe klitscht man sich durch.
Oh, Stellso, okay.
Das ist nett.
Und wie war's so?
Jetzt kommt der Vulkan?
Kommt jetzt der Vulkan?
Ah, so ein bisschen
kann ich mich noch an die Route erinnern.
Genau, jetzt machst du über den...
boostest du dich über den Wasserfall hoch.
Alter, das ist übelst schwer.
Nicht Wasserfall, über den Lavafall.
90er Puls.
Fängt gleich an zu schwitzen.
Das ist übelst schwer.
Ich hab mal nen Stream gesehen, wo das einer geübt hat.
Irgendwie fünf Stunden lang und hat's nicht gebacken bekommen.
Oh, jetzt...
Jetzt hat er geflüstert gerade.
Äh...
Jetzt kommt der Stern, der oben drauf liegt.
Vermute ich mal.
Ah, nee.
Der mit der... der Nessie-Stern kommt jetzt.
Weil man sich schön durch die Decke klitschen kann,
weil sich Nintendo gedacht hat,
YOLO, warum soll man da ne Wand hinbauen?
Stimmt, jetzt gibt's ja von Toad noch nen Stern umsonst.
PC lustig, ja.
Schweiß-O-Meter wäre auch was Tolles.
Genau.
Da soll sich so ein Sensor an die Haut packen.
Stress... Stress-Meter.
Jetzt kommt der Stern.
Nee, nee, jetzt kommt der Stern im Gang.
Oben rechts kommt, glaub ich, jetzt.
Hier, wo man hier an die Wand springen muss,
dann da oben rechts hin.
Und jetzt hat er eigentlich auch schon...
Jetzt hat er genug, oder? Wenn er jetzt 15 hat.
Oder hat er 14?
Nee, einen braucht er noch.
Dann hat er 15, mit 15 kann er in diese Wasserwelt gehen.
Mit 15, 16 mit der Wasserwelt
und dann das zweite Bowser-Level.
Äh, Knärbär, ja, find ich ne gute Idee.
Ich glaub, das machen wir echt.
So, jetzt müsste das Wasserlevel kommen.
Oder kommt der...
Oder kommt der Haas?
Nee, der Haas kommt.
Man braucht ja das Bunny-Ding zum Durchglitschen durch die Tür.
Stimmt, die gehen ja gar nicht in die Wasserwelt mehr rein.
Die glitschen sich durch die Tür durch
und dann glitschen sie sich
mit dem Hase durch die Tür zum Bowser-Ding.
Doch, Wasser, genau.
Blub, blub, blub, blub.
Und jetzt direkt durchschwimmen bis zum U-Boot.
Ja, der Soundtrack ist nice, er ist sehr entspannt.
Düd, düd, düd, düd, düd.
Und hopp, hopp, hopp.
Stern, und jetzt müssten wir ins Bowser-Level kommen.
Und das war, das war auch schon
der letzte Stern, der gesammelt wird.
112er Puls, äh 112er, 113er Puls.
Jetzt ist er aber voll dabei.
Na gut, er merkt jetzt ja
langsam auch, dass es ziemlich gut läuft.
Und jetzt kommen die schweren Dinger.
Da läuft echt alles, ähm,
das sieht so weich aus
von der Bewegung her.
Der bleibt nirgendswo hängen.
Endlich mal, das ist damals gewusst, dass das funktioniert.
Und jetzt kann man sich über die Lava reinboosten.
Gut, das kennt man schon,
das hab ich schon mal gesehen.
Das kennt man ja fast jedem Run.
Aber das sieht so weich aus, die Bewegung von ihm.
Da siehst du, dass der echt
sehr viel Übung hat.
Ich meine, das ist nicht umsonst der Weltrekordhalter,
der sich jetzt selbst
über die Boten hat.
Ah, yes.
So, und jetzt kann er ans Dach.
So, jetzt kommt,
jetzt kommt glaube ich, wenn ich die Route noch
halbwegs richtig in Erinnerung hab,
ähm, jetzt kommt erstmal
genau, quitt.
Dann geht er ins Dachgeschoss.
Dann springt er durch die Decke.
Also er läuft jetzt nicht die Treppe hoch,
dann springt er durch die Decke.
Dann klitscht er sich mit Rückwärtsgespringe
die nächste Treppe hoch.
Genau, durch die Decke springen.
Jetzt zur nächsten Treppe und rückwärts
die Treppe hoch klitschen.
Genau, was übelst schwer ist.
Durch das Tor durch.
Alter.
Corona.
Noch mal rückwärts ins letzte Bowser-Level
und dann sind wir schon fast am Ende vom Run.
Einfach mal das halbe,
einfach mal das halbe Game übersprungen.
So.
Was sagt denn eigentlich der Chat gerade?
Der geht ab.
Das Bowser-Level ist das
schwerste im Game.
Also jeder, der das mal casual gespielt hat,
vor allem wenn er neu mit Jump'n'Run-Spielen damals war,
der hat sich übelst schwer getan.
Hup, hup, hup.
Erstmal komplett ohne Kamera
das ganze gemacht, easy as fuck.
Oh, eine Sekunde verloren.
MonkaS.
Es gab noch, stimmt, es gab damals sogar eine Hotline
bei Nintendo, wo man anrufen konnte.
Jetzt geht der Puls
erstmal runter und ich glaube, jetzt geht der Puls
bestimmt wieder hoch.
Alter, what the fuck?
Was ist das für ein Input?
What the f...
WTF?
Und nochmal, gleich dritter Hit.
Easy as fuck.
Pogu.
Oh, jetzt geht er hoch.
I was here, Pog.
Jetzt, jetzt,
jetzt rastet er aus.
Jetzt rastet er aus.
Jetzt ist er, jetzt ist er,
jetzt ist er nervlich, jetzt ist er vorbei.
Jetzt ist vorbei.
Aber sub 15.
Pogu.
Massive.
Ey, ist voller aus der Puste, aber der Puls
geht nicht hoch.
Rigged Puls Counter.
Der ist fertig.
Aber kann er auch? Ich mein, überlegt euch mal.
Ich bin nicht in Ordnung.
Ich kann nicht.
geometry.
Aber ich kann nicht aufheben.
Ich kann nicht.
Ich kann nicht aufhören.
Ich kann nicht aufheben.
Das ist ja voller Mess.
172.
172, was geht jetzt ab?
Ich kann nicht aufhalten.
Das ist wirklich der Kuss von Peach.
Das müsstest du mal in echt bringen.
Kriegst irgendwann einen Schmatzer und drehst dich erstmal im Kreis und machst Victory-Zeichen.
Was geht denn im Hintergrund gerade ab?
Kamera, ich schieße die Kamera.
Ja, sehr gut.
Also, ähm, wirklich, ich habe jetzt wirklich Schmerzen.
Kamera, ich schieße die Kamera.
Was jetzt?
Er hat Glück, dass...
Er hat Glück, dass er ordentlich ist.
Er hat Glück, dass er ordentlichen Internetanschluss hat, weil in Deutschland wäre während der Übertragung Vodafone zweimal abgekackt und niemand könnte verifizieren, dass sein Run legit ist.
Ich war hier, ich war hier, ich war hier.
Also, da muss man echt was sagen hier.
Definitiv nicht Easy-Clap, sondern einfach nur Clap.
Was ist denn AmarekTV?
Irgendwas Japanisches.
Konfirmation von AmarekTV
Der ist voll fertig mit den Nerven, ey.
Was, was hat der eigentlich da noch?
Der hat danach dann einfach nur eine halbe Stunde gechillt und sich gefreut.
Uey, Pogos.
Äh, falsch, falsch, hier.
Ah.
Falscher Knopf. Aber das war wirklich exzellent. Da hat Panthimo recht. Exzellent. Cool. Nice. Sehr schön.
Das heißt, er hat sich selbst verbessert von 15 und 430 Millisekunden auf 14, 59 und sonst was. Also eine Sekunde schneller als vorher.
Was auf dem Niveau schon ziemlich viel ist. Ich glaube, vor ein paar Jahren haben die Leute noch erzählt, hier Sub-15 ist quasi unmöglich. Aber nice. Sehr, sehr nice.
Haben wir uns doch schon mal was richtig Cooles angeguckt. So, was schauen wir uns als erstes jetzt hier an?
Battlefield Top Plays. Jawohl, Battlefield Top Plays. Eine Runde Battlefield Top Plays. Das geht immer.
Kein einzig Deutscher in der Rangliste.
Es gibt nicht so viele. Es gibt nicht so viele. Hier ist einer mal. Es gibt nicht so viele deutsche Speedrunner, die richtig gut sind. Es gibt ein paar. Es gibt in A Link to the Past gibt es ein paar, die ganz gut sind.
Warum hat er das jetzt nicht gefunden? Gibt es ein paar Deutsche? Gernot ist ganz gut. Genau, es gibt ein paar Deutsche hier, die ganz gut sind.
Das ist aber eher so.
Das war das, was ich mir vorgestellt habe.
Das war das, was keiner mehr hier spielt, den Kram.
Da gibt es ein paar Deutsche, die ganz gut sind.
Bei diesem Randomizer-Zeugs, was auch ganz angefragt ist, sind ganz gut.
Ansonsten, weiß nicht, wie viele deutsche Speedrunners es noch so gibt, die da international richtig gut dabei sind.
Was auch ultra nice ist, wo wir gerade hier Mario 64 auf hatten, der, das gucken wir uns jetzt aber nicht an, der letzte 120, der, oh guck mal, der wurde nochmal überbeaten.
Krass, ich kenne nur den.
Ich kenne nur den hier, den hat, den er live erspielt hat, on-stream in irgendeinem Charity-Event oder was das war.
Oder in irgendeinem Speedrun-Livestream mit noch mehreren Leuten hat er den hier erspielt.
Das war auch ein richtig cooler Run.
Den hatte ich mir auch mal angeguckt, aber 1,38 ist vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen viel.
Und ich wusste gar nicht, dass der mittlerweile schon wieder überboten wurde.
Man muss sich mal überlegen, das ist ein Game, was 24 Jahre alt ist.
Ähm, und da kommen...
Da kommen im Monats- bis Tagestakt teilweise neue Platzierungen, neue Matches rein.
Das ist doch echt, das hätte niemals einer gedacht, 1996, ja.
Vor allem, die spielen auch alle noch auf der Original-Plattform.
Minecraft hat in Deutschland den ersten Place, echt.
Mein Kuh-Eft.
Äh, Java Edition, oder?
Oder welche?
Any% Klitschless, Any% All-Achievement.
All-Advancements.
Komisch, da gibt es gar nicht so viel Random Seed.
Der Honiglecker ist da auf Platz 1.
Ah, excellent.
7 Minuten 17.
Moment, wie spielt man Minecraft in 7 Minuten 17 durch?
Und hier haben wir den RealBinEx mit 24,53.
Mach den mal.
Welchen, den da?
Den Honiglecker?
Der hat schon mal einen richtig steilen Namen, ey.
Besser, besser.
Ach, der Pogger ist lecker, wenn er einen Weltrekord hat.
Was ist das Ziel?
Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer.
Was ist denn das Ziel in Minecraft?
Wie spielt man Minecraft durch?
Der Honiglecker, da ist er, Any%.
7. März, äh, 6. März.
Ender Dragon, okay.
Okay, wir schauen uns das jetzt mal an.
Wo geht's los?
Ich habe hier keinen Schimmer von Minecraft, das wisst ihr, ne?
Easy, erstmal easy.
Erstmal auf easy stellen.
Erstmal die gute alte Pixel-Grafik.
Nicht hier irgendwie RTX oder komische Texture-Packs oder Spinnereien, so, so, so, so classic und raw, wie es geht.
Er atmet.
Wo ist der Pulsmesser?
Ich kann mir, Leute, ich kann mir keine Speedruns ohne Pulsmesser mal angucken.
Ich will wissen, wie viel Puls man hat, wenn man Minecraft in 7 Minuten durchspielt.
Brauch Pulsmesser.
So.
Also, was, was er genau macht, ich habe keine Ahnung, weil ich keine Ahnung von Minecraft habe.
Er rennt erstmal geradeaus.
Warum auch immer.
Ah, er rennt geradeaus bis...
... bis er ein Dorf findet?
Wow!
What the fuck?
Speed Harvesting.
Okay, fahr mal.
Perfekt.
Was passiert gerade?
Und, und, und, und, und, und warum haben die Striche durch den Kopf?
Was passiert gerade? Ich checke.
Was ist das, eine Gold-Axt?
Eine Gold-Axt müsste ziemlich sacken eigentlich, weil Gold ziemlich weich ist.
Geil, das ist Minecraft-Logik.
Was passiert gerade?
Die, die Schafe sehen, haben so ein Ding durch den Kopf.
Das ist irgendeine Debug-Ausgabe oder sowas.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
Was auch immer, aber...
Interessant, ich habe keine Ahnung, was er gemacht hat.
By the way, this is the last one for today.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, was er jetzt gemacht hat. Er hat sich Dinger, Dinger gecraftet.
Was auch immer für Dinger.
Stimmt, stimmt, Janik hat recht, das ist ein, das ist ein Pre-Seed, also pre-seeded irgendwas. Also sprich, der weiß, was kommt.
Also, der weiß, was kommt.
Wahrscheinlich ist das so der offizielle Runner-Seed.
Das ist die Hitbox bei den Schafen, okay.
Was sind das? Hähnchen? Hasen?
Okay, der weiß, woran er hin muss.
Der weiß, woran er hin muss.
Weil das ein bekannter Seed ist.
Leute, da müssen wir uns danach noch ein Random Seed angucken.
Ich glaube, Random Seed ist sogar spannender.
Wir können uns aber die letzten fünf Minuten jetzt noch angucken, weil, ist ja gleich vorbei.
Hat das irgendeinen Sinn, dass der jetzt Holz einsammelt?
I have enough sticks.
Ah, Sticks, okay.
Guck dir Ocarina of Time Randomizer an.
Ich gucke relativ oft A Link to the Past Randomizer,
aber Ocarina of Time Randomizer habe ich, glaube ich, noch nie geguckt.
Also aktuell ist...
Wow, jetzt wird auch noch ein Bötchen gefahren.
Aktuell ist eher so ein bisschen Walking Simulator.
Wahrscheinlich passiert da ziemlich viel,
was ich als Minecraft-Noob nicht checke.
Er baut Betten.
Da man in anderen Dimensionen nicht schlafen kann,
explodieren die und damit macht er Schaden.
Ah, excellent, verstehe.
Wer kennt das nicht?
Das heißt, man killt den Endgegner mit einem Bett,
wenn ich das so richtig verstanden habe jetzt.
Excellent Taktik.
I see.
Ja, das ist aber richtig, Six Head.
Ich glaube, er hat gerade gesagt, übelst gut.
Bötchen.
Für mich so als absoluter Minecraft-Noob sieht das aus,
als würde er planlos gerade auslaufen.
Macht er aber nicht.
Sonst hätte er nicht den...
Oh, nicht den Weltrekord.
Dungeon.
Okay.
What is happening?
Was?
Okay, looten.
Looten.
Das verstehe ich.
Mit looten kenne ich mich aus.
Oh, dude.
Just ignore the timer.
Aha, okay.
Und jetzt?
Ist er jetzt beim Endgegner schon?
The end-to-end-time is not right.
Okay.
Ich dachte, um zum Endgegner zu kommen...
Wie gesagt, ich bin der übelste Minecraft-Noob.
Ich dachte, um zum Endgegner zu kommen, muss man sich selbst ein Portal bauen.
Es gibt ja irgendwie dieses Nether-Portal.
Dann muss man irgendwie da da irgendwie dann noch das End-Portal draus bauen, oder?
Was hat der da für eine Wallhack-UI?
Ich glaube, das ist irgendein Debug-Mode.
Und warum greifen ihn die Endermans nicht an?
Weil er sie nicht lange genug braucht.
Weil er sie nicht lange genug...
What?
Was geht denn jetzt ab?
Weil er sie nicht lange genug anschaut, oder?
Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer.
Was passiert gerade?
Was?
Was passiert?
Was sehe ich da gerade?
Au!
Ja, wenn das Bett explodiert?
Och nee.
So, geht's wieder?
Tweet, Tweet geht raus.
So.
Tweet ist raus.
Schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, wann Vodafone darauf antwortet.
Also ihr wisst ja, die übliche Geschichte.
Wir wollen ja Vodafone möglichst sehr abfucken.
Das heißt, wer auf Twitter ist und mal eine Runde liken und retweeten und vor allem kommentieren
kann, wäre äußerst äh...
Excellent.
Damit die auch wissen, dass die Leute das mitkriegen.
Ganze Krä... Krä... Krätz?
Ist ja Crap.
Alter.
Übelster Huge Crap.
Intershit in Deutschland.
Ist der Wahnsinn.
Aber geht wieder?
Geht wieder?
Ich glaube, es tut wieder, ne?
Also es sollte jetzt, es sollte jetzt gar wieder ohne Problem funktionieren.
Ich glaube, als nächstes verlinken wir denen immer die Clips.
Als nächstes verlinken wir denen immer noch die Clips.
Ähm, was war da fix?
Einfach, einfach drei Minuten gewartet, bis es reconnected ist.
Vielleicht hat er jetzt einen anderen Server genommen oder so.
Ähm.
Äh, die Codes, das haben wir schon.
Das haben wir schon.
Äh, Projektideen.
Tool, das automatisch Vodafone Service antwittert, wenn Stream laggt.
Das machen wir.
Das programmieren wir echt.
Das ist eine richtig gute Idee.
Ähm.
Äh, was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Hahaha.
Äh, nice.
Immer drauf.
Das nächste Mal...
Ups.
Das nächste Mal verlinken wir noch die, die Stream Clips.
Da muss ich sicherstellen, dass ich hier immer meinen Vodafone Shit-Haufen einspreche.
Ja.
Und dann können wir den Link dann...
Dann können wir das verlinken, wie es laggt.
Beziehungsweise, wie es immer wieder abbricht zwischendurch.
Was sind denn das wieder für komische Trends auf Twitter, Deutschland?
Covid-Idioten...
Nee.
Covidioten...
Reproduktionszahl, Körperverletzung, Ansichten und Muttertag.
Okay.
Das oben ist wieder...
Ähm.
Wir kacken uns gegenseitig an.
Und das da unten ist wahrscheinlich der einzige sinnvolle Trend gerade auf Twitter.
Ja.
Trends for you.
Wisst ihr, was schlimmer ist?
Wenn man einstellt, Trends deutschlandweit, dann trendet in letzter Zeit irgendwelche K-Pop-Geschichte.
Es trenden fast nur noch K-Pop.
Ist euch das mal auf Twitter aufgefallen?
Sobald es nen...
Sobald es nen Hashtag gibt, den ihr nicht kennt und ihr klickt drauf, auf einmal ist
das irgendein K-Pop-Zeug.
Oh Mann.
Könnt ihr eben nicht einen 4G-Router mitstellen?
Ja.
Muss ich gleich mal kurz refreshen.
Und jetzt kriegt er jetzt wieder ein Bett drunter gestellt.
Muss jetzt nochmal das...
Warum trifft er den überhaupt?
Hat das Ding so eine Aba...
Ja, der haut ihm auf den Schwanz, Alter.
Das ist aber nicht nett.
Oh mein Gott.
Please, please, please.
Bitte, bitte, bitte.
Come on, bruh.
Ja, Heinub, danke schön für den Sub.
Excellent.
Exquisite Sub.
Poggers, Weltrekord.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt mal den anderen an.
Wir gucken uns den...
Den Random Seed an.
Nee, den...
Hä?
Ah, ich hab das falsche Minecraft auf.
Random Seed.
Real Bennex.
Geht 24 Minuten.
Vor vier Tagen.
Oh, das ist richtig frisch.
Das stimmt schon.
Da hast du recht, Sirius Max.
Da hast du recht.
Der Japaner, sogar der Japaner, ne?
Oh, nee, nee, nee.
Nee, leckt nicht.
Leckt gerade nicht.
Sogar der Japaner ist ultra ausgeflippt, ne?
Und eben, Deutsche bekommen Weltrekord.
Ah, yes, Weltrekord.
Easy.
So nach dem Motto.
Pilzschema.
Ähm, Kappa HD.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Drei Monate, huge IQ Sub.
Dankeschön.
So, und jetzt gucken wir uns den...
Der wahrscheinlich den deutlich interessanteren Run.
Random Seed 24.
Minecraft Weltrekord Speedrun Random Seed.
Nachdem ich immer noch keine Ahnung von Minecraft habe,
bin ich mal gespannt, ob ich halbwegs checke, was da abgeht.
Was ist das da?
Ist das World Random Generator oder was ist das?
Also ich würde den gerade eben als God Seed bezeichnen.
World Render.
Okay.
Oh, Third Person.
Excellent, Third Person.
Leute, ich habe ein Vorschaufenster.
Ich sehe, ob der Stream F ist oder nicht.
Das war kein Savannendorf, das hier.
Aber trotzdem.
Okay, jetzt wird erstmal Holz abgebaut, weil Holz braucht man wahrscheinlich immer.
Das sage ich jetzt als Minecraft-Kack-Noob.
Holz braucht man wahrscheinlich immer, oder?
Also wirklich, hätte man den Seed, hätte RNG gepasst im Nether und halt beim Trade.
Ähm, dann wären in dem Run gerade eben so...
Okay, Steinspitz-Hacke.
Mit einem cleanen End noch.
Aber mit der Aufregung...
Mit einem cleanen End.
Also wenn alles gegönnt hätte, so 24, wäre halt immer noch ultra heftig.
Wie willst du sonst die Explosionenbetten bauen?
Richtig.
Ja, was geht.
Und...
Yo, Kai ist auch herein.
Ich finde das geil, dass Minecraft-Speedruns überhaupt ein Ding sind, ne?
Eigentlich richtig cool.
Erstmal die ganzen Betten mitnehmen.
Stimmt, Zauberwald könnte ich jetzt ausspielen.
True.
Ich vermute mal, dass die Taktik ähnlich ist.
Nur nachdem er jetzt nicht weiß, wo was ist, wird er wahrscheinlich mehr Material farmen müssen
und vielleicht auch selbst ein Portal bauen oder sowas.
Ich hab halt...
Im Gegensatz zu Mario 64 habe ich keinen blassen Schimmer, wie so das Routing und so in Minecraft...
Das Routing.
Das war jetzt für die Cisco-Fans.
Wie das in Minecraft ist.
Auf was man da achtet und welche Reihenfolge man macht.
Was ist das für ein Viech?
Das ist ein Steingolem, ne?
Ja.
Das ist ein Riesen-Golem.
Warum gibt es gelbe Betten und weiße Betten?
Ist da ein Unterschied?
Heilt man in dem einen schneller?
Random.
Okay.
Das ist ein Seed, man.
Okay, anscheinend ist es ein guter Seed.
Ich glaube eh, dass Minecraft-Speedruns extrem davon abhängen...
Also, natürlich muss der Runner auch gut sein, aber wahrscheinlich ist auch extremes Seed-Glück mit dabei.
Wenn du ein Seed hast, wo alles, was du brauchst, nebeneinander spawnst...
Ja, mach ich safe.
Cool.
Da muss ich echt was...
Weil wenn ich gleich ein Dorf...
Wenn ich ein Dorf hab nachher, 100% eigentlich.
Also, ich geh halt dann nachher auf Dorf-Suche.
Weil ich halt auch wieder...
Also, ich könnte da lang, glaub ich.
Da, weißt du, kommt Savanne oder halt hier lang.
Und safe dahinter irgendwo auch noch.
Was ist das denn, Herz93?
Real-Life-Pencil-Sharping.
What?
Hast grad schon nen kranken Run verpasst.
Sicher, war auch lau.
Also, ein wirklich sehr kranken Run.
Was?
Er muss Eisen finden, um einen Wassereimer zu bekommen.
Mit dem Eimer kann er sich ein Höllenportal bauen.
Dafür muss er sich ein Wasser-Eimer finden.
Da findet er...
Äh, was?
Routen, die er für die Augen braucht, um ins Ende zu kommen.
Ah, ja.
Excellent.
Man sieht, wie viel Plan ich von Minecraft hab.
Aber der Chat kennt sich ja aus.
Also, vermute ich mal, wird er jetzt einfach...
Zutaten suchen.
Nicht, dass ich blicken würde.
Was ist das da unten?
Footsteps, Lava, Pop, Item, Plop?
Ach, das ist so ein Eventlog, was passiert.
Ah, jetzt baut er ein Portal, oder?
Baut er jetzt ein Portal?
Oder auch nicht?
Warte.
Ja, das gibt ein Portal, ne?
What the fuck?
Das sieht ja fast so aus, als würde ich das bauen.
Nur, dass er das absichtlich so macht.
Okay, das war das Portal.
Verstehe.
Normal muss er Dias finden.
Ah, Diamanten, okay.
Also, der Knäbel sagt normalerweise...
What the fuck?
Mehr Overlay, please.
Der Knäbel sagt, normalerweise muss er Diamanten finden,
was 20-30 Minuten braucht.
Aber mit einem Eimer kann er sich das selbst bauen.
Okay.
Das heißt, er hat nach 5 Minuten das,
was du normalerweise 30 Minuten verbrauchst.
Die Sounds.
Was ist mit den Sounds los?
To be honest.
Er muss dann
am Dorf sich Augen trainen,
die ihm den Weg zum Portal zeigen.
Ah, yes, excellent.
Ich verstehe alles, Knäbel.
Alles klar.
Augen trainen.
Ich vermute mal, dass es keine
krasse Strat, die zum Run gehört,
sondern er farmt sich XP.
Farmt er sich gerade XP?
Kann das sein?
Interpretiere ich das richtig,
oder muss er einfach die Gegner platt machen?
Ach, die geben Stäbe.
Routen, okay.
Ah, nice.
Eine Runde Routen farmen.
Okay, Stäbe, um Augen zu bauen.
Wer kennt es nicht?
Ich bin mal gespannt,
von was für Augen der Chat jetzt redet.
Was hat er da eigentlich so für
Geblubber um sich drum herum?
Das ist von irgendeinem Trank,
oder von was ist das?
Für den Flex.
Das ist doch auch
alles geplant.
Das ist angeblich Random Seed.
Was er machen muss,
weil er sich auskennt.
Aber den Seed kennt er nicht.
Die Minecraft Sounds,
die sind schon ein bisschen...
Kann man machen.
37 Out ungefähr.
So ein paar Splits wären cool.
Chat, wo lang?
Will da lang gehen, glaube ich.
Was bedeutet,
Random Seed Generator,
vermute ich mal, bedeutet das?
Ich vermute mal,
dass er in einer anderen Welt ist.
Okay, der Knärbär erklärt uns wieder,
wie es funktioniert.
Der Knärbär schreibt,
er wird wohl Holz farmen,
um sich dann Emeralds zu trainen.
Mit den Emeralds kann er sich Augen kaufen
und dann ab zum Ende.
Ist ja fast Overwatch,
ad, ad, Spam.
Ah, yes.
Erstmal schön...
Das Pferd,
ist das getamed?
Der Seed wäre wieder über krass.
Dutzend zwölf,
ich glaube, deswegen ist es auch der Weltrekordrun,
weil er Glück gehabt hat beim Seed.
Let's go, boys.
Let's go.
Der Chat wieder.
Guck mal, da ist ein Pilz.
Jetzt wird der Pilz in die Luft gesprengt.
Oder?
Nee.
What the fuck?
Das gibt jetzt viel Holz.
Oder warum sprengt er das in die Luft?
Warum sprengt er das in die Luft?
Wo ist der Sinn, das in die Luft zu sprengen?
Einfach, dass er es nicht selbst...
Geht schneller, okay.
Dann habe ich richtig gelegen.
Also einfach, weil es viel Drops gibt.
Ach nee, eine Clap.
Okay, verstehe.
So, erstmal eine Runde Holz looten.
Du musst direkt schlafen, dann.
Ja, richtig, wie in echt.
Wer kennt es nicht,
wenn der Förster in den Wald geht
mit einer Box TNT.
Guck mal, einen Appel gefunden.
Einfach einen Löffel reindrücken.
Leute, ich habe legit keine Ahnung,
was 90% der Items machen.
Du musst doch jetzt eigentlich schlafen können.
Ich wollte es schon sagen.
Und wozu muss er jetzt schlafen?
Dass er Ausdauer regeneriert
oder sowas.
Ah, keine Gegner.
Ah.
Nachts kommen Gegner.
Aber wenn man im Freien schläft,
in einem Bett, dann machen einem die Gegner nichts.
Und die Zeit skippt einfach.
Excellent.
Okay, es wird anscheinend jede Menge,
extrem viel Holz gefarmt.
Hä?
Wann waren die Sprengungen so gut?
Ich habe sechs Stacks.
Sechs Stacks?
Gar nicht so ausgesehen.
Oder eher sechs Steaks.
Erstmal ein paar Hähnchen
rösten.
Der craftet sich jetzt Stöcke.
Okay.
Ja, werden wir ja gleich sehen.
Erstmal wieder aufs Horst drauf.
Könnte auch gut auf den Ozean gehen,
anstatt Pferd wieder useless.
Aber beides wäre okay.
Im Down für beides.
Pferd ist useless.
Ach so, wir sind gleich mit der Zeit.
Lol.
Ich kann mich echt nicht erinnern,
wann ich zwei so gute Seeds
direkt hintereinander hatte.
Also zwei so krasse Seeds.
Ja, da sind wir beim Thema,
wo eben im Chat jemand gemeint hat,
das ist schon echt krasser Zufall,
dass er selten so gute Seeds hat.
Mein letzter PB, der war halt
Scufs, den ich gespielt habe.
Aber der war nicht sonderlich gut.
Die Dorfbewohner
Sounds in Minecraft.
Okay, jetzt gibt es jede Menge Sticks.
30 Milliarden Sticks
und dann Emeralds.
Okay, der Knäbel hat recht.
Der Knäbel hat
erzählt, was er macht und
so ist es jetzt auch gekommen.
Also, massive
Chat. High IQ Chat wieder.
Okay, jetzt werden sich drei Spiele an Sticks
gecraftet und dann irgendwie Emeralds
draus gestellst. Was auch immer da genau
passiert. Aber jetzt hat er viele Emeralds.
Mit den Emeralds gibt es Augen.
Was zum Teufel für Augen?
Ich habe in Minecraft noch nie Augen gesehen.
Aber ich habe ja auch nicht wirklich viel Minecraft gespielt.
Ende Augen.
Die braucht er,
um das Portal anzumachen. Aha.
Jetzt ist das wenigstens mal Minecraft.
Jetzt wird wenigstens mal was gecraftet.
Oder wie der Friseur
immer gesagt hat, Minecraft.
Man muss das ja besonders cool aussprechen.
Minecraft.
Was hat er da eben hergestellt?
Das Goldene. Was war denn das Goldene, was er da gerade gebaut hat?
Clothestone.
Und wozu braucht man Clothestone?
Jetzt sag nicht zum Glühen.
Er muss den NPC leveln.
Aha. Okay.
Man levelt NPCs.
Eye of En... Ah, das ist das Auge,
was der Knäbel meint.
Okay.
Ich blicke zwar nicht durch,
aber es ist trotzdem interessant zuzugucken.
Ich glaube, da kann man auch Ozean.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Mr. OP, ja.
Aber da tut sich doch schon seit Jahren nichts mehr.
Bei den Wirt-IO-Treibern.
Gleich werde ich aufgeregt sein, wenn ich in Stronghold gehe.
Sehr aufgeregt.
Die Augen brauchst du dann zum Aktivieren vom Portal.
Okay.
Spieler auf Normal, ich darf nicht joken.
Wenn ich einen Enderman anschaue, bin ich tot.
Sehr wahrscheinlich. Das ist mein Pferd, ja.
Ah, das Pferd schwimmt auch, wenn man drauf ist.
Excellent.
Ein tolles Pferd.
Und woher weiß er jetzt,
wo er hin muss?
Ich check das überhaupt nicht.
Wo kriegt er denn jetzt die Richtung angezeigt?
What?
Was geht denn jetzt ab?
Die Augen zeigen den Weg?
Ja, wo?
In die Richtung, in die das Auge fliegt.
Ah.
Okay, das heißt, er hat jetzt ein Auge geworfen.
Das, was er da gerade gemacht hat, oder so.
Was ich jetzt irgendwie nicht richtig mitgekriegt habe.
Und in der Richtung, wo das fliegt.
Oder fliegt das vor ihm her?
Weil ich sehe nichts.
Also so werfen, wie aus dem Inventar rauswerfen.
Oder wie?
Oder Item benutzen.
Gute Entscheidung.
Ach, nur kurz, okay.
Es fliegt nur kurz, deswegen braucht er da auch mehrere von.
Ah, okay.
Das heißt, er tastet sich da jetzt ran.
Die ganze Weile in die Richtung.
Wirft da noch mal eins.
Ah, jetzt habe ich es gesehen.
Jetzt habe ich es gesehen.
Okay, jetzt hat er es wohl gefunden.
Weil es nach oben geflogen ist.
Ei auf Latan.
Omega-Lul.
Es fliegt nach oben in die Richtung vom Portal A.
Ah, verstehe.
Das ist einfach ein Block in der Luft.
Ich denke, das ist es hier.
Ach, das droppt dann wieder.
Okay.
Kann das Pferd mehr als ein Block hoch springen
oder ist es einfach nur schneller?
Zwei Blöcke und schneller. Aha.
Wir haben hier die richtigen Minecraft-Experten im Chat.
Excellent.
Ah, okay.
Jetzt sieht er, jetzt muss er quasi hier geradeaus in die Richtung weiter.
Jetzt habe ich es glaube ich kapiert.
Pro Chat.
Massive Pro Chat.
Wird hier gleich sein.
Die Pferde-AI buggt.
Moment, das Pferd ist...
Ich dachte, man steuert das Pferd ganz normal mit
WASD jetzt, wenn man drauf sitzt.
Ja, ist auch so.
Wie kann dann die Pferde-AI einpacken?
Aha, jetzt ist er fast da.
Jetzt hat er nämlich gesehen, die Richtung hat sich geändert.
Und woher weiß er jetzt, dass es
exakt da ist?
Gut Glück. Okay.
Raten. Wow.
MonkaS.
Oh, Big Brain Strats.
Ich sehe, ich sehe,
ich verstehe, was er gemacht hat.
Jetzt hat er es direkt gefunden.
Das ist übelst Glück, oder?
Das ist übelst Glück, dass er es jetzt direkt gefunden hat.
Das ist wahrscheinlich deswegen auch,
weil es der Weltrekord-Run ist.
Moin Max, alles gut bei dir?
Ja, alles top.
Ne? Jo? Jein?
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Ja, es ist nur unter dem Auge irgendwo.
Weil er selbst gesagt...
Ah, und jetzt muss er das auffüllen mit den Augen.
Deswegen braucht er auch genau 12
und ein bisschen Reserve.
Und dann?
Nein, und dann?
Naja ja.
Ich glaube, wenn er das 1.
und ein teleportiert,
spawnt man dann irgendwo,
irgendwo random in diese anderen Dimensionen.
Aber die ist nicht so groß, ne?
Das ist wahrscheinlich bloß eine Plattform mit Drache drauf.
Ich habe gesehen, es gibt auch irgendeinen...
...dass der Drache gar nicht der Endgegner ist,
sondern es gibt dann auch irgendwelche noch...
Habe ich letztens in irgendeinem Stream gesehen,
dass es jetzt auch irgendwelche Ender-Villages gibt
oder sowas.
Das ist neu, okay.
Gedreckt.
Er spielt das auf einer älteren Version.
Okay, wahrscheinlich, weil es irgendwelche Klitsches nicht mehr gibt auf der Neuen.
So, jetzt kommt gleich der Betten-Klitsch wieder.
Please.
Ah, trifft nicht.
NA-Aim.
Warum kann ich die nicht treffen?
Huge NA.
Kannst du mir mal das klären?
Einfach erstmal Flying Cheat anmachen und hochfliegen.
Easy.
Ich kreis die nicht.
Jetzt aber.
Und das ist mein Weltrekord.
Ja, daran sieht man, dass das Seed wohl extrem glücklich war auch.
Jetzt kommt der Bett-Klitsch.
Bam.
Oh, das zieht aber richtig viel Energie ab.
Der Drache macht auch nicht so wirklich was, oder?
Ist das schwer, normalerweise?
Ist das ein schwieriger Bosskampf oder eher so easy as fuck, wenn man erstmal da ist?
Was macht das Bett denn?
Äh, das Bett scheint zu explodieren, weil man hier nicht schlafen kann.
So habe ich das vorhin verstanden.
Ne, ich meine, wie schwer der Kampf normalerweise ist, wenn man da legit hingeht oder normal hingeht.
Der Drache ist easy, okay.
Also normalerweise hast du ja wahrscheinlich auch gescheite Waffen, gescheite Rüstung und alles.
Wahrscheinlich sind die Endermans schwieriger drumherum.
Warum hat er eigentlich unendlich Pfeile?
Oder hat er nicht unendlich Pfeile?
Hat er nicht.
Er hat einfach nur viele.
Der Drache.
Produziert Pixel.
Dann sagst du mal wieder eine Runde auf den Schwanz hauen.
Und it's easy.
Ja, nicer run.
Ich weiß es nicht zu würdigen, weil ich keine Ahnung von dem Game habe.
Okay.
Kann das sein, dass sich irgendwie Deutsche bei einem Weltrekord nie freuen?
Ah, gut, geschafft.
Okay.
Oder ist ihm vielleicht auch gar nicht klar, dass das ein Weltrekord ist.
Oh mein fucking Gott.
Deutsche Effizienz, irgendwie erscheint es so.
Ja, nice.
Also, Speedrun hier von Binex.
Wer sich für Minecraft Speedruns interessiert,
kann bei ihm mal vorbeigucken.
Wahrscheinlich hat er noch mehr.
Äh, sehr nice.
Oh, was sagt denn, was sagt denn, was sagt denn Unity Media eigentlich?
Die sagen gar nichts.
Die gehen wieder auf Tauchstation.
Okay.
Der Weltrekord ist halt das Mindeste, genau.
Hast du das Video von Kugelmagazin?
Das war Knet Eddy gesehen zum Thema Battlefield 6, Battlefield 5.
Nee, sollen wir das gucken?
Können wir mal gucken.
Kugel, Kugel, Kugel, Knet.
Ja.
Ich gucke wenig deutsche Videos, muss ich ja dazu sagen.
Äh, das da?
Oder welches, meinst du?
Okay.
Tach.
Ei.
Was geht?
Den KLS-Song?
Nein, den habe ich noch nicht gehört.
Es gibt auch ein paar Sachen, die will ich nicht hören.
Vor allem, vor allem
Warum muss der jetzt auch noch singen?
Es hat ja nicht schon gereicht, dass er nicht mit
Irgendwie seinem Fitnesszeug die Leute gescampt hat
Jetzt muss er auch noch singen
Egal, wir gucken jetzt das Video an
Kein Battlefield 5 Content mehr
Ich fühle mich verarscht
Battlefield 5 Dice EA Rant
Okay
Ja
Ist laut genug?
Ich denke schon, oder?
Also es kommt jetzt noch ein Patch
Aber es kommt kein Content mehr
Ja und der Patch Trailer
Der Patch Trailer sah auch übelst reudig aus
Von wegen diesen Chaptern
Die kommen sollten von der Tides of War
Die ja angeblich
Also zumindest ursprünglich mal gedacht
So sein sollten, dass man quasi den
Zweiten Weltkrieg der Reihe nach mit den ganzen
Auch wichtigen und bekannten Schlachten durchspielen kann
Es gibt keine Amis
Korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege, Leute
Es gibt kein D-Day
Es gibt eigentlich fast nichts
Was man so mit dem Zweiten
Amis gibt es, okay
Aber es gibt fast nichts, was man so wirklich mit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg verbindet
In dem Spiel
Das ist alles gecancelt, da kommt nichts mehr
Was gibt, ne warte mal
Keine Russen, stimmt, Amis gibt es, keine Russen gibt es
So rum war das, ne?
Russen gibt es nicht
Keine Russen, keine Ostfront, kein D-Day, nix
Was du irgendwie so mit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
An Schlachten verbinden würdest
Ach so, stell es so
Karl S. ist jemand, das kann ich mir nicht angucken
Da kriege ich das
Da läuft mein Gehirn aus
Und da muss ich jetzt ganz ehrlich mal sagen
Also allen vorweg
Das ist wirklich der größte Scheiß-Move, den man machen kann
Ich gehöre jetzt nicht zu den Leuten, die
Wie viele andere gemeint haben
Battlefield 5 hätte viel zu wenig Content
Oder manche gehen ja so weit zu sagen
Ja, das hat gar keinen Content
Ich finde, Battlefield 5 hat schon eine Menge Content
Die Maps sind auch riesig, das darf man aber nicht mit anderen Spielen vergleichen
Das stimmt
Aber ich mag es trotzdem nicht
Live-Service-Game versprochen
Was kontinuierlich neuen Content
Neue Fraktionen, neue Waffen, neue Maps
Und wo man von Anfang an mit Content hinten dran war
Schlachten und alles bringen sollte
Und effektiv wird das jetzt alles einfach eingestampft
Und da habe ich absolut überhaupt kein Verständnis für
Jetzt mal den ganzen Corona-Wahnsinn beiseite
Das sind ja Sachen, die kann man vielleicht noch verstehen
Mit dem ganzen Homeoffice, dass sich Sachen verzögern
Finde ich, Battlefield 5 wäre ein Spiel gewesen
Das von vornherein
Einen vernünftigen Support
Ein vernünftiges Image und auch vernünftiges Polish verdient hätte
Stattdessen ist Battlefield 5
Einig ein Spiel, was wirklich von Anfang
Bis jetzt zum traurigen Ende
Komplett von A bis Z
Sabotiert und verdrückt wurde
Und das Ganze kann schon fast kein Zufall mehr sein
Das grenzt entweder an komplette
Die haben sich ja auch selbst debatet
Ich erinnere nur mal an den ehemaligen
Dice-Chef, der noch gesagt hat
Er weiß nicht, wie er seiner Tochter
Erklären soll, dass es keine weiblichen Soldaten gibt
Und wem das nicht gefällt, der soll das Spiel nicht kaufen
Das ist so ein Ultra-Marketing-Fail gewesen
Dass der überhaupt
Wie der es überhaupt macht
Wie der es überhaupt in die Position geschafft hat
Ist mir nicht klar
Oder ist da wirklich einfach Absicht
Und dieses Spiel sollten wir einfach nicht mögen
Nee, die waren einfach unfähig
Die waren unfähig
Das hängt auch schon an mit dem absolut beschissenen Marketing
Das Spiel wurde vorgestellt
In einer Art und Weise, wo die meisten Leute
Sofort die Erwartungen runtergestellt haben
Das habe ich auch schon oft gesagt
Der erste Trailer
War so extrem fail
Vor allem, weil sie
Vorher eine halbe Stunde erzählt haben
Wie realistisch
Wie authentisch
Wie mit Veteranen
Zusammengabe
Was sie alles haben
Und dann kommt der Trailer mit der Frau
Mit der Krallenhand
Mit der Kriegsbemalung
Mit dem schwarzen Soldaten
Mit dem Katana auf dem Rücken
Mit dem Panzer, der durch die Wand fährt
Was nichts, aber auch gar nichts
Mit dem zu tun hatten
Was die ursprünglich erzählt haben
Gedacht haben, okay, dann interessiert mich
Dieses Spiel halt eben nicht
Und wie
Kann man eine Marketingkampagne
So unglaublich verkacken
Nachdem das Vorgängerspiel
So astrein vermarktet wurde
Das stimmt
Erinnert ihr euch noch an Battlefield 1?
Den riesen Livestream, den Reveal
64 bekannte Personen in einem Raum
Zocken Battlefield 1
Kennt ihr das doch, wo Snoop Dogg
Battlefield 1 gespielt hat?
Das war geil
Das hat richtig weh getan
Beim Zugucken
Der hat die ganze Zeit einfach nur
Im Graben gesessen und ist von links nach rechts
Gelaufen
Da hab ich mich so weggepisst
Bei
Nach dem anderen
Das war Promo
Das Spiel selbst war nicht mal meiner Meinung nach
Meiner Meinung nach, bevor alle ausrasten
Meiner Meinung nach war das Battlefield 1 Spiel
Nicht mal so gut, wie Battlefield 5
Eigentlich jetzt sogar spielerisch ist
Aber es hatte einen viel geileren Polish
Es hatte viel geileren Content
Und es hat einfach einen besseren Start
Schon hingelegt, weil es von vornherein
Geil promotet wurde
Diese Streams kamen so gut raus
Das ist richtig
Die Leute hatten sofort Bock
Battlefield 1 zu zocken
Weil diese geilen epischen Schlachten
Du hast direkt Gameplay gesehen
Was hast du bei Battlefield 5 gemacht?
Ein Trailer
Von vornherein wurde das Image also quasi zerstört
Jetzt musst du mal überlegen
Jetzt hast du zwei Möglichkeiten
Ein Trailer an sich ist letztendlich nicht das Problem
Was für ein Trailer
Ist eher das Problem gewesen?
Eins ist, du versuchst dein Image zu retten
Und machst Schadensbegrenzung
Und machst die richtigen Schritte
Oder du machst es wie EA Dice
Und verkackst es nicht mehr
Und verkackst quasi einfach alles
Also im Grunde ist bei Battlefield 5
So gut wie nichts richtig gelaufen
Und keine Entscheidung wurde richtig getroffen
In meinen Augen wurde da einfach von A bis Z verkackt
Und man muss ja sagen, sie haben ja am Anfang
Noch nicht mal großartig irgendwie gelogen
Oder Schwachsinn erzählt
Es war halt schon so, dass sie ein immersives Battlefield gemacht haben
Und auch ein gutes Battlefield in meinen Augen
Aber sie haben halt ein völlig falsches Bild vermittelt
Mit ihrer Promo
Die haben eine Erwartungshaltung an ein Spiel gemacht
Die Leute haben was ganz anderes erwartet
Und anstatt von vornherein klarzustellen
Wie das spielerische Spiel
Wirkt
Haben sie ihre Fantasie von dem Spiel versucht zu vermarkten
Und das kann man nicht verstehen
Wenn man es nicht erlebt und gespielt hat
Und ein Punkt der Schadensbegrenzung wäre doch gewesen
Vernünftige Patches zu machen
Und da muss man jetzt mal ganz klar so sagen
Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre es das erste Battlefield
Was beim Release total verkackt wurde
Und man kann kein besseres Beispiel finden
Als Battlefield 4
Als Battlefield 4 rauskam, ich hab nach einer Woche aufgehört
Es zu spielen, hab es von der Platte geputzt
Und hab wieder Battlefield 3 gespielt
Weil es einfach das bessere Spiel in dem Moment war
Heute würde ich Battlefield 3
Wirklich ausschließlich nur noch aus Nostalgiegründen spielen
Und weil einige Maps wirklich extrem geil sind
In Rush, in Rush vor allem
Das war ja in Battlefield 4 leider nie so gut
Im spielerischen finde ich persönlich
Ist Battlefield 4 in fast jeder Belange mittlerweile einfach besser
Und warum?
Weil sie einen Public Test Server eingerichtet haben
Ein CTE, Community Test Environment
Dort testet man verschiedene Sachen
Und wer keine Lust auf ewige Experimente
Und sich ein permanent veränderndes Spiel hat
Der hat halt nicht auf dem Test Server gespielt
Sondern auf dem Lager
Auf dem Live Server
Und wenn auf dem Test Server sich rausgestellt hat
Dass die Community sagt
Ja, das ist cool, das ist eine gute Änderung
Das können wir machen
Dann wird es umgesetzt
So wurde Battlefield 4 zu einem der besten Spiele
Wenn nicht sogar dem besten Spiel der letzten Jahre
Vor allem, vor allem
Weil sie sich halt auch Gedanken gemacht haben
Und was an dem Spiel geschraubt haben
Und nicht so planlose Änderungen
Wie ich es teilweise in Battlefield 5 mitgekriegt hab
Time to kill runter, time to kill hoch
Time to kill runter, time to kill wieder hoch
Und solche komischen Dinger
Das hat in Battlefield 4, was ja auch einen katastrophalen Start hatte
Einfach strukturierter und sinnvoller gewirkt
Also meiner Meinung nach ist Battlefield 4 eins der besten Spiele
Auch immer noch
Battlefield 1 hat auch Test Server gehabt
Battlefield Hardline hat Test Server gehabt
Man weiß, die Dinger funktionieren und bringen was
Und was macht man bei Battlefield 5?
Man patcht die Time to kill viermal hin und her
Und das auf dem Live Server
Ich hab es nicht gespielt
Aber der Aufschrei war so gut
Der Aufschrei war so groß, dass sogar ich den mitgekriegt hab
Ist doch klar, dass den Leuten das auf den Sack geht
Man hat sich gerade an das Spiel gewöhnt
Man fängt gerade an, es vernünftig zu lernen
Man hat die Waffen drauf
Man hat die Time to kill drauf
Man weiß, wenn ich so lange nicht auf Gegner schieß
Ist der tot, dann kann ich das Target wechseln und so weiter
Und die sagen
Oh, weißt du was, jetzt machen wir die Time to kill mal super kurz
Oh, auch nicht gut, dann machen wir sie mal super lang
Das ist doch nicht wahr
Und der beschissenste Zeitpunkt, den man sich ausdenken kann
Ist der erste richtig große Patch, nämlich das Pacific Update
Ja, stimmt
Als das Update rauskam, war das Spiel gerade dabei, wieder interessant zu werden
Und das sehe nicht nur ich so
Es gab so viele Leute, die wieder Bock auf Battlefield hatten
Das Spiel war gerade dabei, wieder richtig interessant zu werden
Und genau in dem Moment sagen sie
Oh, wir ändern nochmal die komplette Time to kill
Und verlängern die einfach mal
Und das über Monate
Ja, das ist auch eine Sache, die ich mitgekriegt habe
Dass die unglaublich langsam waren, was das Ganze anbelangt
Auf der einen Seite hier auf Service Game und Dauer Content
Und Dauersupport und Update und sonst was machen
Und dann langsamer sein mit Patches als Blizzard bei Overwatch
Nach Monaten blieb die Time to kill, wie sie war
Also klar, es gibt Ausnahmen
Und wenn ihr da draußen einer von den Leuten seid, die sagt
Mir gefiel das besser, das ist völlig okay
Aber der große Teil der Community hat gesagt
Das ist Schrott, das wollen wir nicht
Macht es zurück, das war vorher gut, das Spiel ist jetzt gut
Lasst es so
Nein, es wurde durchgezogen
Und was ist das Ende vom Lied jetzt gewesen?
Nach Monaten wurde die Time to kill wieder so hingepatcht, wie sie davor war
Sie hat monatelang Zeit verschwendet für nichts
Wie bescheuert kann man sein?
Und anstatt, dass diese Zeit für vernünftigen Content oder richtige Patches gebracht wurde
Wurde sie einfach vergeudet
Und jetzt merken sie, oh ja, wir werden wohl nicht fertig
Ja, das ist schwer zu sagen
Also da muss ich sagen
Für uns, so als Außensteher, sieht das so aus
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie da sinnlos rumgehampelt haben den ganzen Tag
Und sich denken, ja, wir machen jetzt mal hier, wir machen jetzt mal da
Die werden da schon einen gewissen Plan gehabt haben
Der halt nach außen hin nicht aufgegangen ist
Also ich glaube nicht, dass DICE wirklich Zeit vergeudet hat
Im eigentlichen Sinne, dass sie
Dass sie sinnlose Sachen aus ihrer Sicht
Oder dass sie sinnlose Sachen gemacht haben
Die haben das schon für den besten Weg gehalten
Ähm, es war halt für den Arsch, ne
Einfach kein Content mehr
Was ist das denn?
Also ich bin wirklich ehrlich, bei mir seht ihr kein Battlefield 5 mehr
Oh, Rage Mode
Jetzt ist Rage Mode activated hier, ich sehe es schon
Werde ich wahrscheinlich einfach löschen
Also löschen will ich sie wahrscheinlich nicht
Aber ich werde es auf jeden Fall erstmal nicht bringen
Ich werde Battlefield 5 weder streamen, noch irgendwelche Highlight-Videos machen
Ihr kriegt trotzdem Battlefield, aber da spiele ich echt lieber Battlefield Bad Company 2
Battlefield 3
Bad Company 2, Poggers
Oder Battlefield 1
Fuck it, was solls, Digger
Jetzt ist Battlefield 1 auch wieder interessant
Auch wenn es spielerisch vielleicht meiner Meinung nach nicht so gut ist wie Battlefield 5
Das wenigstens fertig gemacht worden
Da gab es wenigstens Maps und Content
Und das ist ein fertiges, polishedes Game
Also ich finde es eine absolute Frechheit, nach der ganzen Misere zu sagen
Oh, da machen wir halt einfach gar nichts mehr
Was solls
Es ist ein Live-Service-Game versprochen worden
Und die Leute haben das Spiel gekauft in dem Wissen
Das, was jetzt drin ist, ist nicht alles, was ich für den Markt bekomme, das ich ausgegeben habe
Das ist ein Spiel, das langfristig sparen kann
Aber das ist ein schönes Beispiel dafür, wie es gehen kann
Das muss jedem klar sein im Endeffekt
Wenn man sich jetzt was kauft für Versprechen, die abgegeben werden
Das ist das Gleiche
Es ist in ähnlicher Form das, wie wenn du Sachen vorbestellst
Wenn du Sachen vorbestellst und denen jetzt schon deine Kohle gibst
Es ist fast genau das Gleiche
Du bestellst die Sachen vor mit dem Versprechen
Dann kommt das, was du haben willst
Was absolut nicht klar ist
Vor allem in der heutigen Zeit nicht klar ist
Wo teilweise Spiele rausgeschissen werden
In einem Zustand, wo du dich fragst
Hat das mal einer selbst von denen Probe gespielt?
Was machen soll
Und anstatt, dass es überhaupt irgendwann mal Spaß gemacht hat
Wurde es hin und her kaputt gepatcht
Und Sachen, wo man sich fragt
Wieso ist das eigentlich immer noch ein Bug
Die werden einfach nicht gefixt
Mal ganz abgesehen davon von den immer noch total katastrophalen Menüs, die nicht funktionieren
Ewigen Anzeige-Bugs
Dass man manchmal einfach nicht mehr spawnen kann, weil die Maus nicht funktioniert
Was sind das für Fehler?
Nö, lieber 20 mal die Time-to-kill-Patchen
Sehr sinnvoll
Also für mich war der Gipfel der Dämlichkeit dann erreicht
Als sie dann Firestorm rausgebracht haben
Firestorm ist für mich
Einer der besten Battle Royales, die bisher rausgekommen sind
Habe ich von vielen
Ohne Scheiß, Leute
Ich habe es nie gespielt
Habe ich von vielen Leuten schon gehört
Aber das ist total runtergegangen, Firestorm
Du hattest keine Legs
Die Hit-Rack hat gut funktioniert
Das Plattensystem hat auch gut funktioniert
Warzone hat es übernommen von Firestorm
Es war ein sauguter Battle Royale
Aber kein Mensch kauft sich für Battle Royale Battlefield
Das macht keiner
Ja, Free-to-Play
Das hätten sie wirklich Free-to-Play machen müssen, ja
60 Euro ein Battle Royale Spiel
Das gibt Free-to-Play-Alternativen
Das gibt Early-Access-Alternativen, die günstig sind
Warum sollte irgendwer einen Vollpreis für Firestorm ausgeben?
Und damit nicht genug
Und selbst wenn es komplett gerechtfertigt wäre
Die Leute, die haben im Kopf
Das ist ein Spiele-Genre
Da gibt es hier was weiß ich
Fortnite, PUBG und Gedulds
Also sprich Spiele, die im Endeffekt nichts kosten
Und
Okay, bei PUBG, weiß ich nicht
Bei PUBG musst du immer noch kaufen
Und das kriegen die Leute einfach nicht in den Kopf
Frei zu sagen
Ah ja, ich kaufe mir jetzt ein Battlefield, um Battle Royale zu spielen
Egal wie gut das ist
Aber das hätten die Free-to-Play machen müssen
Das wäre die einzige Chance gewesen
Ähm, ja, Warzone ist umsonst, ich weiß
Deswegen funktioniert es ja auch so gut
Nicht nur, dass sie den guten Battle Royale hinter einer Paywall versteckt haben
Obendrauf bringt Electronic Arts, der eigene Publisher
Zur quasi selben Zeit
Apex
Eins der besten Free-to-Play Battle Royales raus
Das es gibt nämlich Apex Legends
Wie bescheuert kann denn Timing und Planung bitte sein?
Das stimmt, das ist wahr
Egal wie gut das Battle Royale ist
Wenn ein Free-to-Play Battle Royale Hype am Start ist
Wie er seines gleichen sucht
Was ist das für ein dämlicher Scheiß?
Apex hat aber auch ein bisschen verkackt, wenn man sich die Viewerzahlen anguckt
Warzone
Die ganzen Apex Leute spielen jetzt Valorant
Ein Free-to-Play Battle Royale hätte Firestorm sein können
Und Firestorm hat die meisten Elemente, die Warzone hat
Firestorm hätte locker diesen Hype
Diesen Hype, den Warzone jetzt hat, auch haben können
Sie hätten es nur im Free-to-Play machen müssen
Das habe ich damals gesagt und ich sage es heute
Und sie hätten es, sie sollten es immer noch machen
Sie sollten immer noch ein Battlefield Battle Royale rausbringen
Was Free-to-Play ist
Lernt doch mal was von Activision
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass ich das mal sagen würde
Aber lernt von Activision
Und auch da, für mich einfach die totale Sabotage
Also das wirkt wie Sabotage
Wie kann man denn von dem eigenen Publisher
Was ist das für eine Entscheidung?
Die wissen genau wann die
Das ist eine Stonks Entscheidung
Games rauskommen
Die wissen genau wann der Battle Royale Modus rauskommt
Die wissen genau wann Apex Legends rauskommt
Und was macht die?
Die sagt sich auch, weißt du was
Titanfall hat so oft
Haben wir so oft zwischen zwei große Releases gepackt
Wahrscheinlich war das einfach eine Wiedergutmachung
Vielleicht haben sie einfach nur gedacht, weißt du was
Jetzt muss Battlefield mal eins an die Fratze kriegen
Aber was ist das bitte für eine Geschäftslogik?
Also für mich ist das klar
Battlefield 5 ist für mich in dem Moment gestorben
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe viele Sachen habe ich noch
In Anführungszeichen verteidigt oder gerechtfertigt
Hab gesagt, passt auf Leute
Dafür ist aber das und das
Das Spiel als solches ist auch gut
Es gibt viele Dinge, die stören mich nach wie vor nicht
Dieser ganze Hate, den das Spiel abgekriegt hat
Meiner Meinung nach nicht gerechtfertigt
Einfach eine CTE einrichten
Wo die Sachen getestet werden können
Das Spiel als solches laufen lassen
Und fucking Content bringen
Wie versprochen
Aber ich wette mit euch
Es lag daran, dass kaum einer was gekauft hat
Weil es ja auch kaum was zu kaufen gab
Wären da ein paar geile Skins bei gewesen
Die man sich für ein paar Euro hätte kaufen können
Hätte ich vielleicht auch reingecasht
Das einzige, wofür man wirklich echt Geld hätte ausgeben können
Waren Elite-Skins
Und die haben mich einfach nicht interessiert
Aber das ist doch nicht meine Schuld
Das passt dann aber wieder nicht zusammen
Also wenn es ein Vollpreis-Spiel ist
Dann erwarte ich auch keinen Ingame-Shop
Aber ich weiß, das ist in der heutigen Zeit
Da schon komplett utopisch sowas anzunehmen
Natürlich haben Vollpreis-Spiele auch Ingame
Guck dir WoW an
WoW, alter
ETF, Corona
World of Warcraft ist das schlimmste Game
Was mittlerweile Monetarisierung angeht
Ohne Scheiß
Du musst das Game kaufen
Du musst, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich das neueste Addon noch kaufen
Du musst einen Monatsbetrag bezahlen
Und
Du hast Ingame-Cash-Shops
ETF
Was ist mit Blizzard los
Also das ist
Du hast wirklich
WoW ist wirklich, ist alles
WoW ist Pay2Play
Ne, warte mal
Was gibt es da alles?
Pay2Play?
Ach frag mich nicht
Alles, alles
Alles, es hat alle Formen drin
Besseres überlegen
Oder keine Live-Service-Games mehr rausbringen EA
Ihr habt es einfach nicht drauf
Dieser Scheiß macht mich einfach echt wütend
Vor allen Dingen, weil das so ärgerlich ist
Denn Battlefield 5 ist im Kern wirklich ein richtig geiles Spiel
Das hätte eins der besten Spiele der letzten Jahre wieder werden können
Möglich
Ich habe es nicht großartig gespielt
Es ist klar, dass das nächste Battlefield halt frühestens in 2-3 Jahren kommt
Wahrscheinlich sogar noch länger
Die sollen sich Zeit nehmen
Ganz schön große Downtime für ein Battlefield, oder?
Jetzt endlich fertig raus
Es bringt sonst nichts
Dann richtet gleich einen Test-Server ein
Sofort Day 1
Und dann testet ihr dort alle Änderungen, die ihr plant
Und dann hört ihr auf die Community
Ne, du kannst hier im Ingame-Shop einen Level-Boost kaufen
Das ist schon mal was
Eigentlich drauf, die arbeiten eigentlich gut mit der Community zusammen
Aber es ist ja auch so, dass die Besetzung geändert wurde
Wahrscheinlich wurde da die Besetzung geändert
Oder was, sind andere Leute am Werk
Andere Leute, die die Entscheidungen fällen
Aber wer auch immer das verkackt hat, schönen Dank auch
Ich kann nur sagen, ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf Battlefield 5
Ich werde es nicht mehr zocken
Weil ich absolut keinen Sinn darin sehe, ein Spiel zu spielen
Was so verkehrt lief
Was so verkackt wurde
Und je mehr Leute das jetzt noch spielen
Desto schlimmer wird es
Weil die werden jetzt sehen, oh Mensch, die Leute kommen
Also ganz ehrlich, noch eine Message an alle
Die jetzt noch gerne aktiv Battlefield 5 spielen
Ist eine schwere Entscheidung
Aber tut mir den Gefallen
Und gebt keinen müden Cent mehr in diesem Shop aus
Denn dieses Spiel hat es nicht verdient
Mehr als den Kaufpreis zu bekommen
Tut mir leid, ich habe auch hunderte Stunden da reingesteckt
In das Spiel
Habe auch hunderte Spielspaßstunden damit gehabt
Ich habe den Kauf nicht bereut
Aber ich bereue es auch nicht, im Shop nicht eine Mark ausgegeben zu haben
Denn das Ergebnis sieht man ja jetzt gewiss
Wie eine heiße Kartoffel
Und das geht mir mega auf den Sender
Und jetzt bin ich gespannt, was ihr davon haltet
Ballert es mir in die Kommentare
Schreibt mir eure Bewertung da
Das hilft mir natürlich ungemein
Und euch kostet es nur einen Klick
Danke und Tschüss
Ja, kann ich nachvollziehen
Wie gesagt, ich bin ja jemand, der hat das Spiel nicht wirklich gespielt
Ich habe es nur so aus der Ferne alles mitbekommen
Voll für den Arsch
Der Clown Fanatiker sagt im Chat
Seine Hoffnung wäre, dass dieser Lootbox Track
Einfach als Glücksspiel verboten wird
Ist ja in immer mehr Ländern so
Würde fast alle Spiele besser machen
Würde auch die Langzeitmotivation steigen
Weil man sich einfach etwas
Erkrankten muss
Das Problem, was ich darin sehe
Wenn Lootboxen und sowas verboten werden
Also ich finde das
Erstmal gar keine schlechte Idee
Solche extreme Glücksspielmechaniken
Zu verbieten
Aber
Das wird nicht dazu führen, dass es verschwindet
Die werden einfach
Die Sachen
Geschickt umschiffen
Habt ihr das mitbekommen
Wo war das, in Frankreich und CSGO
Mit dem Scanner
Da siehst du mal, wie es laufen kann
Also ich glaube das war in Frankreich
Und ich versuch das mal so wiederzugeben
So gut ich das aus dem Kopf wiedergeben kann
In Frankreich haben sie verboten
Dass du Lootboxen
Zufallsinhalte
Also dass du nicht weißt
Was in der Lootbox drin ist
Also sprich, dass es halt
Dass es insofern halt
Zufällig ist, dass du halt nicht weißt
Bevor du Geld ausgibst, was du bekommst
So
Also
Was haben sie gemacht
Bei CSGO in Frankreich
Du musstest dir einen Scanner kaufen
Und mit diesem Scanner
Konntest du quasi Lootboxen
Vorher scannen
Und du wusstest schon was drin ist
Bevor du dafür quasi Geld ausgibst
Die Sache ist nur die
Und warum es schlimmer ist
Eigentlich warum es fast schlimmer ist
Als die ursprüngliche Variante
Du kannst die Lootbox nicht verwerfen
Also du kannst nicht sagen
Ich habe jetzt diese Box gescannt
Der Inhalt gefällt mir nicht
Ich mache die nächste Box
Das geht nicht
Du musst die Box öffnen
Dass du weitermachen kannst
Also im Prinzip
Es ist eigentlich überhaupt kein Unterschied
Ja
Nur, dass sie sich jetzt rausreden können
Ja also vom Gesetz her
Sagt wir dürfen keine zufälligen Inhalte
Anbieten
Wie bieten wir jetzt keine zufälligen Inhalte an
Trotzdem kannst du die nicht mehr kaufen
Also
Eigentlich noch größerer Scam
Nur mit dem Zusatz
Du musst einen Scanner kaufen
Na gut den Scanner
Warum es den Scanner überhaupt zu kaufen gibt ist
Dass du dir keine neuen Accounts erstellst
Dass es sich nicht lohnt neue Accounts zu erstellen
Weil du musst ja Geld ausgeben
Da war der richtige Stonksmann am Start
Das ist richtig gut eigentlich
Da war der Gabenpöks
Persönlich wahrscheinlich am Start
Hat's gedacht
Ah yes
Lass mal die Franzosen noch ein bisschen mehr scammen
Also da sieht man das das reine verbieten von Lootboxen überhaupt nichts bringt
Das ist schon High IQ
Das ist Massive IQ
What Battlefield 6 needs
Wir haben schon so viele Battlefield Videos angeguckt
Ich also
Ich hab noch ein paar andere Battlefield Videos
Die wir gucken könnten
Passt ja gerade thematisch dazu
Wir können uns einmal das Neue von Levelcap angucken
Was er da Meinung ist
Da bin ich sogar mal gespannt was er sagt
Oder wir hätten noch ein Top Place
Oder
Wir scheißen erstmal auf Battlefield und gucken was anderes an
Wenn als nächstes
Bad Company 3 kommen sollte
Mache ich mir Sorgen dass es die verkacken
MRP67 sehe ich genauso
Ich glaube erstens
Mittlerweile auch nicht mehr dran
Das Bad Company 3 kommt
Und
Ich
Denke auch wenn sie
Es rausbringen sollten
Dann ist es verkackt
Dann werden sie es verkacken
Hat eigentlich Vodafone geantwortet
Mittlerweile
Huge Comment
Der Chat
Der Chat schlägt auch auf Twitter zu
Ich sehe es schon
Trasteros
3 Monate
Huge Subscription
Big Brain Sub
Ups
Okay
Zocker Imperium sagt
Hör mir auf mit Vodafone
Ich hab vor über einem Monat einen Support angeschrieben
Hab täglich Internetabbrüche
Ja willkommen im Club
Die Vodafone Hackermans sind am Start
Aber wahrscheinlich kriege ich jetzt wieder als Antwort
Bitte nochmal den Router neu starten
Okay also
Was haben wir als nächstes
Was können wir uns noch so angucken
Windows 98 PC
Festsplatten Backup auf VHS
Was ist mit AOL passiert
Eine neuen Akku
Warum hab ich ein Akkuschrauber Video auf
Ein Akkuschrauber Video auf
Warum hab ich das
Ich glaub ich weiß warum ich ein Akkuschrauber Video auf hab
Weil ich den vorgänger Akkuschrauber hab
Genau ich hab mir das Video gebookt
Weil ich den
Ne, nicht wegen der Verlosung, weil ich den Vorgang gehabt habe, weil ich wusste, weil ich wissen wollte, ob es sich lohnt, das abzucraden.
Aber lohnt sich wahrscheinlich nicht, denke ich mal.
Ja, weil den habe ich mir vor einer Weile mal gekauft, das ist ja mein aktueller Akkuschrauber.
Und jetzt gibt es ja anscheinend den da.
Was ist eigentlich preislich der Unterschied?
100, 115 Euro?
Okay, das ist der ohne Bohrer.
135 kostet 157 Euro.
Ja, also da würde ich mir wahrscheinlich jetzt den kaufen, wenn ich mir jetzt neu kaufe, aber lohnt sich ja nicht.
Warum sollte ich das jetzt nochmal neu kaufen?
Mich interessiert ja mal, was da rausgekommen ist jetzt.
Niemals beim Akkuschrauber.
Hä, was meinst du, Churok?
Twitch-Zuschauer schreibt, ich verstehe nicht, warum Vodafone so ein Dreck ist.
Jeder, der dort ist, beschwert sich und läuft schon lange so.
Tja, anscheinend gibt es noch genug Geld.
Der neue Akkuschrauber hat jetzt Lootboxen für Bits.
Ja, das wär's doch mal.
Das wär's doch mal.
Es ist ein Akkuschrauber, wenn der alte noch geht, lohnt sich eigentlich nie ein Upgrade.
Denke ich auch.
Ich will mal gucken, was rauskommt am Ende, was er sagt.
Ich kenne die Videos von dem, der erzählt erst mal eine halbe Stunde.
Der erzählt jetzt erst mal eine halbe Stunde was.
Das ist ziemlich uninteressant.
So die erste Hälfte meistens.
Ich will einfach nur mal die Tests sehen.
Okay, Längenvergleich.
Längenvergleich.
Neue Akkuschrauber, alte Akkuschrauber, neue Akkuschrauber.
Im Grunde halte ich sie.
Aha, das ist wahrscheinlich der Neue, das ist der Alte, ne, doch, das ist der Alte, das ist der Neue.
Aber das ist einer mit Bohrfunktion.
Kann man nicht so wirklich, wenn man das hier wegnimmt, dann, ja, so ein Größenunterschied ist nicht, der wiegt die Dinge am Anfang immer, zeige mal.
Wiegt er die, wiegt er die auch, wiegen, Waage, wo ist die Waage?
Okay, Unterschied, hat ein bisschen mehr Power, dreht sich ein bisschen schneller.
Ist ein bisschen kürzer.
Ah, hier, so, okay, Unterschied.
Also der wiegt ungefähr ein Kilo, der, den ich jetzt habe.
Haben hier nur rund 900 Gramm.
Ja, nur 900 Gramm.
Das ist doch echt Wahnsinn.
Und jetzt schauen wir uns mal die etwas ältere Generation an.
Hier zwar mit Schlagwerk, aber trotzdem.
Ja, das merkt man ein bisschen, aber großartig, naja.
Okay, ich will die Tests, ich will die Tests sehen.
Tests, beste, beste, ah, excellent, excellent.
Tests, Tests, Tests, Tests.
Das muss ich mir angucken, vom Akkuschrauber.
VayXox sagt,
hab letztens den Vodafone Support angerufen,
weil wir über Wlan immer wieder Verbindungsabbrüche haben.
Ins WAN LAN klappt, über Kabel geht's auch,
nur Wlan ist kaputt.
Fazit des Support- es kann nicht an der Fritzbox liegen,
die wir von den mieten,
es muss daran liegen,
dass 2,4 und 5 Gigahertz Wlan dasselbe ssid haben.
Das haben die mir auch erzähl.
Das haben die mir auch erzählt.
Genau das gleiche haben die mir auch erzählt.
Nur mit dem Unterschied,
nur mit dem Unterschied,
ich verwende das WLAN von der Connectbox
gar nicht.
Ich verwende weder das WLAN von der Connectbox
noch,
oder von der Fritzbox,
bei mir ist es eine Connectbox,
ich verwende das gar nicht von denen.
Das ist so die random Bullshit-Antwort von denen.
Okay.
Nur kurz das Fazit.
Was sagt er denn zum Akkuschrauber her?
Eiche?
Oh, Eiche.
Eiche.
Und hier haben wir Fichte.
Excellent Slow-Motion-Bohren.
Ah, yes.
Ich gucke sowas gern.
Ich finde das irgendwie
entspannend zuzuschauen,
wie Löcher in Holz gefräst werden.
So, jetzt nehmen wir hier den 35er.
Ah, jetzt der 35er.
Excellent.
So Bohrer habe ich überhaupt nicht.
Aber für so einen kleinen 12V-Akku-Schrauber
ist das schon nice.
Zeig mal, wie gebohrt wird.
Das ist ein Akku-Schrauber,
also kein Akku-Bohr-Schrauber.
Trotzdem möchte ich euch zeigen,
wie er sich schlägt.
Hier einmal in Poroton
und einmal sogar in Kaltzahnstein.
Aber was, was,
was ist denn so eine Hauswand?
In der Regel?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich vermute mal auch,
dass wir sowas hier haben in der Wand.
Moin, Sibaro.
Ah, yes.
Okay, das heißt,
ich könnte auch mal ein Loch damit in die Wand bohren.
Excellent Slow-Motion-Bohrung.
Das Ganze hier ist ja ein Akku-Schrauber.
Und jetzt kommen wir auch endlich zum Thema.
Ah, guck mal, den Vera-Bit-Halter,
den habe ich auch.
Da hier, das Teil.
Excellent.
Excellent-Teil ist das.
Der Vera-Bit-Halter.
Schrauben.
Wir haben hier,
wie immer,
die übliche 20 Zentimeter.
What the fuck?
Die Schraube ist so groß wie sein Kopf.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie so eine fette Schraube
irgendwo reingeschraubt.
Die üblichen Schrauben.
Teilgewinde-Schraube
und 20 Zentimeter Vollgewinde.
Das ist schon eine echte Herausforderung.
Hätte dich nicht als Heimwerker eingeschätzt.
Ja, so Heimwerkern in Form von irgendwelchen,
irgendwelche Regale bauen oder so,
bin ich auch nicht so scharf drauf.
Ja, mache ich, was gemacht werden muss.
Aber für mein ganzes Heim-Automatisierungs-Zeug
ist es halt auch ab und zu mal erforderlich,
dass man ein paar Sachen macht.
Excellent-Bit-Halter.
Kann ich nur empfehlen.
Na, geht doch gut rein.
Gibt's ihm.
Oh, es geht sogar wieder raus.
Das heißt, er hat noch genug Power,
weil wenn das Ding,
wenn das so voll am Limit ist von dem,
was es von der Leistung her, was es kann,
dann kriegst du meistens die Schraube, die du nicht mehr kannst.
Meistens die Schrauben nicht wieder rausgedreht.
Aber da hat wohl noch ein bisschen Reserve.
Oh, jetzt kommt die Fette.
Jetzt kommt die Fette.
Oh, ja, aber gerade so.
Und ob die wieder rausgeht?
Oh, nice.
So, jetzt haben wir gesehen, wie er schraubt.
Und ich muss sagen, die Schraube ist immer noch ein bisschen heiß.
Die 20-Zentimeter-Schraube, Vollgewinde,
hat er in das Holz reingeschraubt.
Ja, ich glaube, das würde meiner nicht schaffen.
Ich glaube, das würde meiner nicht schaffen.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, ich schraube solche Schrauben auch nicht rein.
Reicht schon.
Ich meine, komplett.
Kommt noch im Test.
Okay, nice.
Quanta Costa, 150 Euro.
Der alte, den alten kriegst du für 115 gerade.
Also, sag mal so, den alten kann ich wirklich empfehlen.
Das hier ist der, das ist der alte, genau.
Das ist der, den ich habe.
Auch dieses, auch genau dieses Set hier mit diesem Standardzeug dabei.
Ich glaube, es gibt zwei Akkus dabei.
Den kann ich echt empfehlen.
Wenn man ab und zu mal was bohren muss,
aber hauptsächlich quasi braucht, um entweder irgendwo Löcher rein,
also irgendwelche 3D-Drucker oder so, irgendwie Löcher reinzumachen
oder mal irgendwo eine Kamera an die Wand zu machen
oder hauptsächlich Sachen irgendwie schrauben.
Das Ding kann man echt empfehlen.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Das Ding ist wirklich nicht übel.
Das, das, das kann man, kann man, kann man empfehlen.
Ja, mal gucken, ob Vodafone geantwortet hat.
Ah, yes, nein.
Hehehe.
Ja, es kann schon sein.
So, ähm, Seroxinio, neun Monate schon.
Ja, anscheinend, aber, danke schön.
Huge Subscription.
Samus Climer, Samus, Samus, Samus Climer.
Danke schön, nice.
Gut, jetzt haben wir uns sogar nochmal ein Akkuschrauber-Video angekündigt.
Guckt ihn.
Excellent, excellent, excellent.
Building a better Windows 98 PC.
Leute, ich brauch ein bisschen, bisschen, bisschen Computer-Nostalgie-Zeug.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Windows 98 Rechner.
Außerdem gucke ich Videos von ihm gern.
Wahrscheinlich, weil er so Oldschool-Kram macht.
Wir spulen ein bisschen vor.
30 Minuten ist ganz schön hart.
Mal gucken.
Und willkommen zu einem LGR-Computer.
Das sieht, das sieht übelst kaputt aus, das Ding.
Also übelst, übelst verstaubt.
Ah, excellent, ja.
Ja.
Ah, jetzt kriegen wir, jetzt kriegen wir die Teile.
Jetzt kriegen wir die Teile gezeigt, was reinkommt.
Ein Bot, der checkt, ob da Vodafone-Support geantwortet hat.
Ah, das ist eine gute Idee.
Oh, das ist richtig cool, das könnte man im Projekt nehmen.
Tool, also wir machen ein Tool, das automatisch Vodafone-Service antwortet, wenn er streamlegt.
Und eine Notification postet, wenn der Support antwortet.
Und, was ganz wichtig ist, was wir auch noch brauchen.
Automatisch das Vodafone-Shit-E-Mode aufmacht.
Ganz excellent, exquisit wichtig.
Ja, first off, got a 3.5-inch, 1.44-meg floppy disk.
Habt ihr noch sowas?
Gibt es noch irgendjemand von euch, der wirklich den Diskettenlauf erkannt, was funktioniert?
Ähm, ich glaube nämlich, dass die aktuellen Gehäuse dafür gar keinen Einschub mehr haben, oder?
Ja.
Ähm, habt ihr, okay.
Haben die dafür überhaupt noch einen Einschub?
Ne, gibt nix mehr, kein Einschub mehr.
Hab noch die Install-Disketten für Windows 98.
Oh, Poggers.
Ich hab noch ein Windows 98 Lizenzhandbuch mit Sticker und Zeug drauf.
Disk Drive hier, just standard black drive.
But I am going to be using one of these here.
This is just a regular one.
No, this is not, dang it.
This is a CD-ROM-Drive.
Well, I meant to pick up a DVD-ROM from my storage.
I guess I didn't.
I know I have a couple.
Anyway, I'm going to put it...
Die Zeit, wo man so CD-Laufwerke hat, ähm, damals, damals ging's drum, wer hatte das schnellste CD-Laufwerk?
Da kamen die ersten an, so nach dem Motto, oh, Marc, ich hab jetzt ein 20-fach, oh, ich hab ein 24-fach, ich hab ein 32-fach, ich hab ein 48-fach, ich hab ein 52-fach, ich hab ein 72-fach CD-Laufwerk.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das schnellste war.
Ich glaub, 72, oder?
Oder 52?
72?
Ja, 72-fach.
360?
Also, ich glaube, das schnellste für so die Normalsterblichen war 52-fach.
Worauf bezieht sich die 72 dann der 72 mal schneller als einfach?
Einfach ist das, womit du Audio-CDs abspielst.
Was kann Blu-Ray?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich will es von innen sehen, ich will das von innen sehen.
Ah, ein Noctua-Lüfter!
Das ist aber nicht 1998.
1998 hat man die billigsten China-Lüfter.
Oder einen Zahl...
Nee, später hatte man einen Zahlmann-Lüfter.
Genau, Papst-Kühler hatte man damals. Richtig.
Ist das ein SD-Kartenleser, oder was soll das sein?
Ih, was ist das für ein Ding?
Ein SD-Karten-IDE-SD-Kartenleser.
What the fuck, was es alles gibt.
Es funktioniert nicht wirklich...
Es war nur ein kurzes...
...Fix.
You know, I never intended this to be permanent.
And because it's a project box, I really didn't care about aesthetics too much.
But I've begun to care, dang it.
So I don't want to use this anymore.
I was thinking about just going to this front-loading 3.5-inch Drive-Bay CF-Adapter instead.
Oh, Kompaktfisch.
But I just don't want to use compact flashcards anymore.
And unfortunately I cannot find any SD-Kartenleser.
Start-Taste gibt es heute noch.
...IDE-Adapters that go...
Oh, das ist was Neues.
...in the front like this.
I mean, I could make a custom bay if I had a 3D-Printer or something, but...
...you know...
...als Netzteile noch oben im Gehäuse verbaut waren, ja.
...I tried to...
Ja, ja.
Das...
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das Standard ist mittlerweile.
Ich weiß, meine letzten zwei, drei Rechner hatten das alle unten verbaut, aber ich dachte, es ist nur in etwas teureren Gehäusen so, und die meisten haben es noch oben.
...drimmling something out, and I was not happy with my results.
So, I found this instead.
What we've got right here...
...is an SD-Kartenleser.
...to SCSI adapter...
...to SCSI adapter....
... IRS instead of IDE.
Same basic idea, but it's a frontloading one, and it has, uh, black three and a half inch drive bay bezel.
...und USB.
So frontloading...
So was gibt es?!
...so was gibt es?!
Moment.
Es gibt SD-Karten und micro-USB zu SCSI adapter?!
Meine Güte!
In Heroic Why,こんにちは franc нашего fiel 남자.
anstatt nach hinten zu gehen.
Und dann hat es auch ein kleines Micro-USB da,
für, äh, was weiß ich.
Aber egal. Ich denke, das wird gut funktionieren.
Und ich habe bereits eine SCSI-Karte drin,
also hoffentlich ist es nur ein Thema,
dieses 50-Pin-Kabel zu öffnen und es zu machen.
Die Technik kommt, um zu bleiben.
Auch gleich mal ordern.
Soundkarte. Oh, exzellent.
Ein Sound-Blaster.
Oh, 64 Gold. Okay, die hatten so...
Das ist eine ISA-Karte.
OMG, Alter.
Das ist noch pre-PCI-Steckplätze.
Ich habe nie eines dieser Modelle benutzt.
Ich habe einige der späteren benutzt, aber...
War die... waren die schon immer so gelb?
Oder sind die jetzt einfach so gelb geworden mit der Zeit?
... ich habe... ich weiß gar nicht, wann.
Es ist egal.
Es ist einfach eine coole Karte.
RCA raus und alles.
Aber sie gibt mir mehr Kompatibilität
für DOS-Games und OPL3.
Ich meine, was ich hier habe,
ist die Aurel Vortex II-Karte.
Das könnte tatsächlich sein.
Und das hat eigentlich eine ziemlich dezenten DOS-Emulationen.
Für Dinge wie FM-Synth,
Ad-Lib-Kompatibilität und...
Was hat er denn eigentlich für dicke, grüne
Kabelschläuche?
Eigentlich eine richtig gute Idee
für die damalige Zeit, weil
damals hattest du ja keine modularen Netzteile.
Und die Rechner, die waren alle zugehonken
mit IDE und
Power-Kabeln.
... aber es gibt viele meiner Lieblings-Games,
vor allem Shareware-Games, die nicht so gut funktionieren.
Ich denke, wenn ich es richtig aufsetzen kann
und ich sicher bin, dass es keine Konflikte gibt,
dann kann ich beide inserieren.
Ob ich die beiden gleichzeitig verwenden kann,
weiß ich nicht.
Aber zumindest kann ich beide inserieren und
eine oder die andere abwenden, abhängig von meinen Bedürfnissen.
Also, das machen wir jetzt.
Wir legen alles zusammen und...
ich weiß nicht, spielen ein paar Spiele oder so.
Man muss aber echt mal sagen,
dadurch, dass die Noctua-Lüfter
so hässlich aussehen,
passen die ziemlich gut in so einen Oldschool-Rechner.
Excited.
Die sehen fast aus wie 1998, nur dass sie neu sind.
Oh, MonkaS.
Du hast hier ein paar Sachen.
Schau dir das an.
Aluminium-PC-Case,
für High-Performance-PC-Systeme.
Oh, jetzt.
Exzellent.
Exzellent Werbung.
Sie haben sogar Aluminium-Bezels für CDs und...
Das ist so viel tiefer, als ich gedacht hätte.
Oh, das war's, was ich gesagt habe.
Keine Sorge, Mann.
Ich bin auf diese Stelle aufgeregt.
Oh, Junge.
Back it up.
Doch, Noctua-Lüfter gibt es mittlerweile auch in schwarz.
Das ist...
Das ist wirklich gut zusammengebracht.
Sie sind sogar ein bisschen...
Oh, diese alten Dinger.
Okay, das ist ein halbwegs neues Gehäuse,
aber es sieht wirklich aus wie ein Gehäuse von 1995.
Nur eins muss man sagen,
das Gehäuse sieht deutlich weniger scharfkantig aus
wie 1995 Gehäuse.
Die Gehäuse damals...
Du hast dich geschnitten an den Ecken.
Die waren wirklich ziemlich schlecht.
Die waren absolut...
Um nichts zu sagen,
die Gehäuse waren total Bullshit damals.
Okay, also...
Oh, Mann.
Das kommt sehr gut zusammen.
Oh, Maumkais.
Viel einfacher als das andere Gehäuse, das ich momentan benutze.
Junge!
Ich habe einige Komponenten und Sachen.
Ja, Junge.
Guck dir das an.
Ich habe sogar kleine...
Protektive...
Plastik...
Ja.
...Bitte hier.
Wiederum, um sicherzustellen, dass du dich nicht auf diese scharfen Ecken beschleunigst.
Mal sehen, was hier ist.
Okay.
Ein Schild.
Eine ganze Menge Schrauben.
Rubber.
Stand-Offs.
Manche...
Stimmt.
Du hast recht.
Und den Kram hier muss man nicht rausbrechen.
Sowohl da als auch da.
Bei vielen Gehäusen damals war es so, dass teilweise die...
So ein Schutzding hier bei den Slots dahinter war und hier vorne an den Laufwerkschächten,
dass es dort nicht zum Rausschrauben war, sondern dass man ein Stück Metall rausbrechen musste.
Und da hattest du das Problem, wenn du es einmal rausgebrochen hast und dann an der Stelle
keine Karte mehr oder kein Laufwerk mehr haben wolltest.
Dann hast du da einfach ein Loch im Gehäuse gehabt.
Und ich habe damals dann einfach halt einen Laufwerk reingeschoben, obwohl ich sie nicht
gebraucht habe, weil halt...
Weil ein Loch im Gehäuse doof aussieht.
Und die Gehäuse haben damals so unglaublich Staub angesammelt.
Heute hast du ja bei einem guten Gehäuse, wie beispielsweise bei so einem Fractal Design
eher...
Wo sind die jetzt?
Eher 5, 6, 7...
Hast du vorne ja einen ordentlichen Staubfilter und sowas drin.
Und wenn du darauf achtest, dass mehr Luft aus dem Gehäuse rauskommt.
Äh, Schwachsinn.
Dass mehr Luft in das Gehäuse reingeht, wie rausgeht, dann kriegst du auch kaum Staub
drinne.
Also musst du einfach gucken, dass immer ein bisschen Überdruck quasi im Gehäuse
ist.
Die sind definitiv nicht von 98.
Guck.
Wir haben da noch ein bisschen das Signature Tan & Brown da.
Aber egal.
Gut, dass ich die hier habe.
Wie bekommt man den Überdruck da rein?
Na einfach mehr Lüfter, die reinziehen, als Lüfter, die rauspusten.
Wir reden ja nicht hier mit was, wo du irgendwie eine Druckluftflasche aufladen kannst.
Wenn du vorne drei Lüfter hast und hinten einen ist schon mal gut.
Dann hast du ein bisschen Überdruck im Gehäuse und...
Einfach hinten was draufzukleben.
Das Funktioniert.
Das funktioniert. Klar funktioniert das.
Sollte es nicht funktionieren.
Leute,
Überdruck, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel gesagt
gewesen. Einfach gucken, dass
mehr Lüfter Sachen reinziehen
als rauspusten.
Oder war es umgedreht?
Dass mehr Lüfter rausziehen
als reinpusten.
Nee, nee, nee. Wenn mehr Lüfter
reinziehen, dann kommt Staub rein.
Ach, scheiß drauf.
Was auch immer. Wurscht.
Er meinte, mehr Lüfter rauspusten.
Ach, was weiß ich.
Scheiß drauf. Das Wichtigste ist,
einen Staubfilter vorne dran zu haben am Gehäuse.
Dort, wo die Lüfter sind, die reinziehen.
Ich habe meinen PC,
ohne Scheiß, seit ich die Fractal Design Gehäuse
habe, ich habe die letzten drei
PCs nicht einmal sauber gemacht
und die sind alle komplett,
komplett rein innen drin.
Das funktioniert.
Die Luftfilter sind echt gut.
Die Staubfilter.
Also, so Dinger,
so advance Sachen hatten die Gehäuse
damals nicht.
Die Gehäuse damals musstest du erst mal
dir eine Zerrung
im Rücken holen, wenn du da einen Rechner
zusammengebaut hast.
Und dann putzt du es zusammen,
ich glaube, hier drauf und dann
slide it all into place.
That, I like this already.
Oh yeah.
Well, let's go ahead and get everything
out of this one, well, all the components
that I want to keep anyway and put them in here
and get Windows 98 going with some games.
Yeah, it's disassembly time.
Ja, und die Gehäuse damals,
da hat der Herz 390 recht,
die hast du teilweise richtige Probleme
gehabt auseinander zu kriegen.
Vor allem das Front,
die Front vom PC,
die Front vom Gehäuse,
die du teilweise aufmachen musstest,
wenn du neue Laufwerke einbaust.
Das war ein Riesenakt manchmal.
Welches Fractal Design hast du?
Ein R4, ein R5 und ein R6, glaube?
Oder was habe ich?
Moment, ich sag's dir.
Ich hab FPS,
Selbstbaurechner,
ich hab doch hier,
ja,
das habe ich gerade.
Gerade das R5.
Davor hatte ich auch schon zweimal Fractal Design,
weil, beste.
In schwarz, ja.
In schwarz mit der Klappe vorne dran
und einem Fenster nebendran.
Oh, Zeitraffer, Zeitraffer-Stecksohren.
Was ist denn das?
Was ist denn das, was da rausguckt?
Ist das das Ende,
das Ende von einem,
was ist denn das?
Das Ende von einem 5 Zoll
Diskettenlaufwerk?
Ja, ne? Er hat Mundgeruch.
Bester Name. Würde ich auch sagen.
Würde ich auch so sehen, ja.
Das ist das Ende von so einem 5 Zoll Diskettenlaufwerk.
VIA Chipsets?
Ne, das ist genauso, wie es keine Nvidia Chipsets mehr gibt.
Ja, diese
unterschiedlich gefärbten IDE-Konnektoren.
Da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern.
Wo es dann hieß, ja,
hier musst du die Festplatte dran machen
und hier machst du das CD-Laufwerk dran.
Da musstest du die Sache auch nicht
ordentlich jumpern,
sondern es hat einfach funktioniert.
So, die gute alte Parallel-Port ist auch noch am Start.
Schöne DIP-Switches noch auf dem Mainboard
für Takt einstellen.
Es gab ja mal eine Zeit,
da hat man seine CPU übertaktet,
indem man so einen Switch auf dem Mainboard geswitcht hat.
Und das BIOS konnte man rausstopfen.
Ja, stimmt, das gab es auch noch.
Okay, also, das Mainboard
muss ich mir mal kurz angucken.
Was?
Das ist aber kein Retro-Main...
Moment.
Was ist das für ein fucking Main?
Was ist das?
Das ist ein AGP, oder?
Das ist ein AGP-Slot?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Also, was ist denn das da oben?
Also, das ist ein AGP.
Das ist PCI-PCI.
Was ist denn das da oben?
Das ist ein umgedrehter PCI?
Einen falsch rum
halblängen PCI?
Ist das für eine interne PCI-Karte?
Die man nicht
rausführen will, oder was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Kein Plan.
Der erste, was heute
Standard ist, glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein PCI-Express ist.
Es sieht aus wie ein PCI-Express,
aber PCI-Express
auf einem Board mit einem ISA-Anschluss.
So was gibt es nicht.
Ein PCI-Express plus ein
ISA-Port, das sind 20 Jahre
dazwischen, das glaube ich nicht.
Ich gebe dir aber recht, dass es aussieht wie PCI-Express.
Aber das könnte ein PCI sein. Einfach
einen kurzen, kurzen PCI. Falscherum.
Oder so. Was auch immer.
Ich muss das Panel zuerst öffnen.
Ich bin so weit gekommen,
dass ich das ganze
vorbeigelegt habe, bevor ich es erkannt habe.
Da sind wir.
Jetzt, mit dem Schild in Position,
können wir es öffnen.
Exzellent, jetzt passt es.
Zeig mal, was hat er denn für
einen Schraubendreher?
Was ist denn das?
Alright.
Zeit für ein paar Karten.
Voodoo 3 Karte hier.
Oh, eine Voodoo 3.
Pogos.
Aureal Vortex 2.
Ethernet-Karte,
die ich in diesem System
noch nicht benutzt habe.
Wenn man sich überlegt, der ganze Shit ist heute
einfach alles on-board, bis auf die Grafikkarte.
SCSI-Controller.
Und unser Sound Blaster
Awe64.
Das habe ich noch nicht
neben dieser Aureal-Karte installiert,
also schauen wir mal, wie das funktioniert.
Wenn man sich überlegt,
kein Wunder, dass die Boards
heute alle nur noch so kurz sind hier.
Der ganze Kram ist ja alles on-board.
Aber ich weiß nicht,
wie es euch da geht.
Ich habe so eine gewisse...
Ich will das nicht wieder so haben.
Ne?
Ich finde das besser,
wie es heute ist.
Ich will das nie wieder so haben,
aber ich verspüre,
wenn ich so ein Video sehe,
ich spüre eine gewisse
Begeisterung.
Innerlich.
Wenn ich sowas sehe.
Ich will das auf keinen Fall mehr so haben.
Das ist deutlich angenehmer,
wie das heute so ist.
Big Brain.
Einführung.
Es passt alles.
Das glaube ich ihm.
Es ist eigentlich komplett sinnlos,
sich so einen Rechner zu bauen,
fällt mir gerade mal ein.
Wozu?
Aber es geht.
PC-Speaker muss sein.
Ohne PC-Speaker geht das gar nicht.
Wobei, PC-Speaker kann man schlecht anmachen.
Oh, Pains, Pains-Champ.
So viel Platz in dem Gehäuse.
Das ist nicht normal für die damalige Zeit.
Normalerweise waren die Gehäuse vollgestopft
mit irgendwelchen Kabeln noch.
Let's get them installed.
This is such a cool case.
This is not sponsored.
I really like this.
Listen to this.
Was gibt das Gehäuse-ASMR?
So, I think I'm gonna put this here.
The screw goes right here.
Okay, well.
I guess that's what this little contraption is for.
Das war damals auch gang und gäbe,
dass man die ganzen Cages rausschrauben musste.
Und teilweise richtig ätzend,
wenn du was ändern wolltest
und erstmal alles andere abstöpseln musstest,
dass du den Cage rausschrauben kannst.
That's kind of an annoying design,
dass man nur ein Set of screws
auf jeder Seite hält.
Ach, wird schon halten.
Das wird schon halten.
I think I'm gonna put it the other way around.
Because at least it'll smush downward
onto the floppy drive.
Ja, komm, das hält schon.
That makes more sense.
Excellent.
Excellent Montageskills.
Nice.
We're gonna unbox this lovely thing.
Ah, ist das ein Diskettenlaufwerk?
Oh man.
Opening these new old stock drives never gets old.
By definition it gets old.
Anyway.
Damals konntest du theoretisch,
wenn du wolltest, sogar noch selbst Teile auslöten.
Fantastic.
Ich hab keinerlei persönlichen Bezug
so richtig zu 5 Zoll Diskettenlaufwerken.
Das war ganz kurz so vor meiner Zeit.
Oh, das Stream lag, Leute.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Haben wir ein Bild?
So, jetzt sollte es wieder funktionieren.
Das ist so lächerlich in Deutschland.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Ne, das hat sich jetzt wieder eingekriegt.
Die Chatkommentare sind live, wenn ihr refresht.
Das passt.
Excellent.
Also wie gesagt, ich werde jetzt jeden
Ausfall werde ich an Vodafone twittern.
Oh, oh, oh, Leute.
MonkaS.
Es hat geleckt.
Ich hab's gesehen.
Die blocken mich irgendwann, dann kriegen die auch irgendwann kein Geld mehr.
Okay, gucken wir weiter.
Nice.
Kündigung schon raus, nee.
Ich muss ja auch erstmal, dass ich kündigen kann,
also dass ich schneller kündigen kann,
muss ich auch erstmal eine Weile zeigen,
dass es Probleme gibt.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich den doch irgendwann noch offiziell auch dazu auffordern,
Abhilfe zu schaffen, was auch immer.
...
weit gebogen und gezogen, dass sie teilweise so scharfkantige Ecken drin
hatten, dass sie theoretisch fast schon nicht mehr funktionieren konnten, aber es
ging trotzdem irgendwie. Hast du jetzt eigentlich endlich deine SSD geändert?
Ja natürlich, daran wird es liegen. Klar habe ich die geändert.
Felix sagt, muss mich bei mir zwischen 1 Gigabit Vodafone und 25 MB Telekom
entscheiden. Ja, ist bei mir ähnlich, nur dass ich theoretisch den Luxus habe, 250 MB
VDSL zu bekommen. Also das wäre dann gar kein so großer Verlust.
Was gibt das für ein Fertig...
Was gibt das für ein Fertig ist?
Haha, exzellent, exzellent Kabel-Logik.
Hängt ein bisschen nebendran. Oh, ein Pentium 3. Das war aber, das war aber für die Zeit schon sehr advanced.
In der Tat gibt es einige verschiedene Dinge, die ich bereits verbessern muss. Ich bewege das hier runter, damit ich das Kabel...
Oh, dieser Sound von Diskettenlaufwerken, wenn das Ding startet. Und immer nicht zu
vergessen und das machen die Computer teilweise heute noch,
dieser Post-Beep. Erinnern euch noch manche an den Post-Beep, dass das
Ding gebootet hat, dann hat es gemacht... am Diskettenlaufwerk und dann hat es
irgendwann gemacht... und dann war fertig. Dann hat es gebootet.
...which is actually what I did with the other one. I forgot about that, the whole A and B priority thing.
Anyway, when it loads up the SD-Card, it's not actually looking at the card itself to just see what it is.
It actually goes to whatever the default is on the board itself and then just tries to
load the card.
...based on the defaults, which, the defaults weren't good. It was set to like 2GB
Hard Drive and I have a 64-Gig card in there, formatted to 32 gigs and that was
set for the IDE configuration that I had on the other build for this Windows 98 PC.
So I had to actually... Ich guck mir so... ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich aus Nostalgie-
Gründen ist, weil es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, oh, ich will das wieder so
haben. Also ich finde das mit der Technik wie das heute ist viel, viel besser als es
damals gewesen ist, also auch
dass alles on board ist und dass die
Gehäuse ordentlich sind und alles
aber so gewisse
es freut mich, wenn ich
ein altes Mainboard mit
5 Einsteckkarten sehe
oder auch wenn ich ein 3,5
Zoll Diskettenlauf
irgendwie freut mich das so innerlich
ich kann nicht beschreiben, woran das liegt, aber
irgendwie gefällt mir das
und ich will es auf keinen Fall wieder so haben
das ist so ein typisch schöne
Windows UI, wo jeder sofort
versteht, was Sache ist
sehe ich das richtig, dass der Windows
von der SD-Karte
von der Flash-Karte
bootet, anstatt seine Festplatte einzubauen
ist vielleicht gar nicht schlecht, ist bestimmt besser
als eine Festplatte
so ein Peggelspiel
dafür brauche ich Windows 98
Insomniac Dude gebe ich
direkt
und vielleicht PC Welt ist teilweise echt
echt cringe
und allein schon, dass das Ding Höllenmaschine heißt
ist auch ziemlich cringe
hier, plugged in and working, and I
had to take out the Ethernet card,
I don't know, for now, because
I was trying to get both of those sound cards working
and I was running into some IRQ-Conflicts.
Stimmt, aber es hat so Interrupt-
Adressen-Konflikte und so was
mit Einschubkarten, ja.
Und soll ich einfach mal erzählen,
die Linux-Community
damals, weil ich flame ja
da immer ganz gerne immer ein bisschen auch dagegen.
Ihr wisst, dass ich mein Geld mit Linux verdiene
und auch ansonsten viel unter Linux
mache, das ist nicht besonders so, dass wir hier extra immer Linux
vor allem laufen haben mit Zeug.
Aber das ist wieder so ein typisches Beispiel gewesen,
dass manchmal
Sachen unsinnig
lange dauern, gerade was Linux
angeht und bei vielen Open-Source-Projekten.
Als die angefangen haben
bei, unter Mac und unter
Windows, zu sagen, okay,
manuelles Zuweisen von
Interrupts und Adressen und so
ist für den Arsch, kannst du eigentlich keinem
zumuten und langsam aber sicher
angefangen haben, wo es dann ein bisschen
mehr
Richtung USB ging, bisschen mehr Richtung
Plug-and-Play, automatische Adressenzuweisung
und sowas ging, haben die unter Linux
damals gesagt, den Scheiß braucht
keiner.
Man muss, man sollte, also
wer Adresszuweisung,
IRQ-Geschichten nicht versteht, sollte
keinen Rechner verwenden. Das wollen wir nicht
in Linux haben. Das haben die ernsthaft
damals erzählt, ja.
Wo man halt auch wieder sieht, dass
da sehr viele PPGA-Leute dabei sind.
Die wollten von her, die wollten
das wirklich manuell konfigurieren,
müssen. Nicht die Option
haben, es manuell zu konfigurieren, die wollten,
dass man es manuell konfigurieren muss,
weil nur das der einzig richtige Weg ist.
Und das,
so Sachen hast du heute noch,
wo sie Zeug nicht gebacken bekommen.
Oh, ein halbes
Gigabyte RAM.
Ein halbes Gigabyte RAM, das ist ja schon
massive.
The Aureal Vortex 2 Sound Blaster
Pro Emulation, because we just don't need it.
We've got the proper Sound Blaster
in here now. The only thing that
isn't really working is the Joystick
Port on the Vortex.
Ja gut, kann man mitleben.
The Joystick Port, das habe ich ja schon
wieder komplett verdrängt, dass damals
Soundkarten Joystick Ports dran
haben. Ich habe bis heute,
nicht verstanden, warum ausgerechnet die
Soundkarten
IO Ports noch dran hatten für Joystick.
Check this out.
Let me just show you.
Look at all these MIDI Synths I have.
Yeah, I got MIDI Synths.
Und? Brauch ich kein Match?
Midi, Alter!
Midi?
Wer A hier als Midi?
Oh, excellent!
Oh, das wird ja besser hier!
Ich hör keinen Unterschied!
Warha!
Okay, ich glaub das Interessante von dem Video ist vorbei.
Oh!
Unreal Tournament!
Ich will Unreal Tournament spielen!
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt!
Wenn es lädt, dann störe ich.
Dann stürzt es ab, oder wie ging das nochmal?
Das war noch Zeug.
Das waren Memes, bevor es Memes hieß.
Tro M? Nein, kenn ich nicht.
Aber excellent Video!
Ich guck mir gern so ein bisschen
Nostalgie-Stells an.
So, das ist mein aktueller Rechner, den wollte ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Was haben wir sonst noch so zu tun?
IoT, Backdoor-Kamera
...
Best Burger I've ever made.
Leute, es ist bald Zeit fürs Mittagessen.
Es ist 13.10 Uhr.
Wir können uns entweder das Köpfen
von der neuen Intel-CPU angucken,
oder wir gucken uns den Burger an.
Hercules Beats heißt er heute.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Wir gucken uns aber kein 26-Minuten-Video an.
Ich will einfach nur mal sehen,
wie er die CPU köpft.
Ah, excellent!
Hier geht's los.
Ich will sehen, wie die CPU geköpft wird.
Ich will...
Ah, yes, da.
Ah, hier, hier zeig ich das.
Ich habe ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt,
wie sehr ich geschwitzt habe
bei dem 8700K.
Oh,
Alter, mit der Rasierklinge.
Alter, das tut mir weh, wenn ich das sehe.
Ah, Hilfe!
Gleich ist die CPU-Rip, ey.
Monka!
S.
Au!
Ach nee, das ist der Heatspreader.
Das ist okay.
Da kann man rumkratzen.
Okay, wir kriegen gar nicht gezeigt,
wie die CPU geköpft wird.
Das ist ein G-Baited-Video.
Okay, dann ist er langweilig.
Okay, der beste Burger.
Alter, 22 Minuten
will der Burger machen.
Was ist da los?
2.0
Also, ich nicht.
Kurze Frage,
was bringt CPU-Köpfen?
Naja, wenn man das so wie Intel macht
und Wärmeleitpaste zwischen
Heatspreader und CPU macht
und die nicht verlötet miteinander,
dann hat man ziemlich schlechte
Wärmeableitung von der CPU
zum Heatspreader.
Also, Heatspreader ist der Deckel
von der CPU.
Also, wenn du so ein CPU in der Hand hältst,
das Metall, was oben drauf ist,
ist die Wärmeleitpaste von diesem ganzen Case.
Und Intel hat dazwischen
Wärmeleitpaste geschmiert.
Zwischen innen der CPU an sich
und dem Deckel.
Und normalerweise
wird das verlötet
und dann ist die Wärmeübertragung wunderbar.
Und wenn du das köpfst, heißt es im Endeffekt,
du machst den Deckel ab,
machst die Wärmeleitpaste raus,
die dazwischen ist
und machst irgendeine Flüssigmetallmischung
dazwischen, die besser die Wärme leitet.
Und das bringt extrem,
wirklich richtig viel.
Also, ähm,
ich hab
mein 8700K geköpft
und, weil ich den übertakten wollte,
und er ist, wir haben es
im Stream gemacht, müsste man sich
raussuchen, ja. Und
der ist jetzt glaub ich 20 Grad, 15 oder 20 Grad
kühler. Das bringt wirklich massiv viel.
20 Grad.
Ja zeig, bester Burger.
Excellent.
Hä? Mach hinne.
Ich will den Burger sehen.
Was ist denn, was ist mit denen
los, äh?
Wo geht's denn los?
Wo, wo geht's hier los mit, mit, mit, mit
Burger? Oh.
Warte mal kurz. So.
Ich geh mir jetzt auch was zu Essen holen, klar.
Und ich geh mir jetzt was zu Essen holen.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Und dann brauchen wir
Pickle.
Und Pickle ist ein wichtiges Teil von diesem.
Und hier hab ich was.
Ich hab ein kleines Dill.
Mach es ein Dill, mach es nicht eines dieser süßen
Sandwich-Pickles. Oh, wir mögen
diese nicht, oder?
Also diese Leute, wir schneiden sie in kleine
Planken. Siehst du das Wort,
das ich hab? Und dann in diese Weise.
Und dann in diese Weise, um ein kleines
Baby-Dice von Pickles zu machen.
Baby-Dice of Pickles.
So.
Ich bin wieder am Start.
Ich ess jetzt was nebenbei.
Was macht der denn da?
Gewürzgurken schnippeln.
Also Leute, ich hab jetzt paar Nudeln.
Nudeln mit Lachs drin. Easy.
Ich futter mal kurz
meine Nudeln.
Ah, ey, schmeckt richtig gut.
I love seeing the chunky Pickles in here.
More is much better.
Aber, der ist ganz schön langsam, oder?
Ich will doch keine halbe Stunde
gucken, wie er da seine Soße macht.
Ich will den Burger sehen.
I use
a Kitchen-Aid-Mixer.
Ich will den Burger sehen.
See this, the little, uh,
the plate that's in here.
Jetzt macht er das Hackfleisch noch selbst, oder was?
Der macht jetzt sogar
das Hackfleisch selbst. Wir gucken gleich,
Barbecue-Pit-Boy ist noch eine Runde hinten dran.
Oh, das ist nix für Veganer
heute.
Ich will den Burger sehen. Wo ist der Burger?
Jetzt, jetzt, wird gebrutzelt.
Excellent.
Aha.
Da ist ein Stück Finger mit drin.
Auf beide. Und warten.
Wir warten, bis sie am meisten
der Fläche herunter kochen.
Vielleicht ein paar Minuten. Wir werden anfangen,
die Süße auf den Topf zu bekommen,
und das sagt uns, dass sie fertig geflipst sind.
Dann geben wir unseren Käse hinzu.
In der Zwischenzeit können Sie sehen,
dass unsere Onionen süß sind.
Die Karamellis warten, bis sie aufgebildet sind.
Wir nehmen unsere Buns.
Butter diese Jungs.
Ah. Okay, da macht er schon mal richtig.
Eins haben wir ja bei den
Barbecue-Pit-Boys gelernt. Man macht,
alles mit seinem Messer. Also Löffel oder sonst was ist verpönt. Gabel, Löffel, man muss alles
mit dem Messer machen. Mit der Machete, stimmt. Mit der Machete. Ah, die Juices. Any Juicers.
Also für die BBQ-Pitboys wäre das jetzt ein bisschen wenig Fleisch. Da muss der Burger
mindestens so dick sein wie das Brötchen hier unten. Das wäre für die fast schon
vegan.
Ah, okay, okay, geht. Leute, wir müssen noch eine Runde das Original gucken.
Tikiya Burger. Meinst du, dass durch die neuen Konsolen 4K 120, 144 Herzmonitore erschwinglicher
werden? Die sind doch schon, also 4K 144. Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass das in nächster
Zeit Standard wird.
Ah, hell yeah.
Komm, we are grilling up some tequila tortilla chip burgers at the pit. And it's real easy
to do. For this recipe you're gonna need your ground beef, some seasoning, like SPG, you're
gonna need some hot sauce, you're gonna need some good buns. You got some bell peppers,
cream cheese, we got the onion, pickled jalapenos, mayonnaise, we got tortilla chips. Those are
corn tortilla chips. Chili peppers. And here's the magic. Your favorite tequila.
Nachdem ich nicht so der Alkoholtrinker bin, ich habe gar kein Favourite Tequila.
Zumindest wenn ich es machen würde, würde ich definitiv keinen Lidl Schnaps nehmen,
weil das ist bei allem abartig.
Also wer mal probiert hat den Unterschied zwischen einem ordentlichen Whisky und einem Lidl Whisky,
da sind Welten dazwischen, der Lidl Whisky schmeckt, nicht nach Chemie, aber schmeckt
schon fast, wie soll man das beschreiben, so als möchte man es gar nicht schmecken
und wenn man irgendwie was halbwegs ordentliches hat, dann schmeckt das relativ süß und gut
eigentlich.
Boah, es gibt das was fertig ist, boah das ist doch totaler Matsch danach.
Ich habe überhaupt keine eingelegten Jalapenos.
Boah.
Just shut up.
Starts to taste good.
Here you want to take those chopped jalapeno peppers and add them to the ground beef.
Now if you want to know the exact ingredients, how much, what we are doing, head on over to
our website.
And once Pedro uploads the recipe to our site.
You can download it and print it out.
Wow.
That's easy to do.
Moment, das habe ich nicht zugeguckt.
Warum hat er?
Macht er seine Hand auf dem Fleisch liegen?
Einfach nur so?
Bruna.
Erstmal anstecken alles.
Siehste, man muss alles mit dem Küchenbeil machen.
So gehört sich das.
Es ist so, als ob man ein bisschen mehr Fett mit dem Küchenbeil dazugeben würde.
Und es ist auch so, als ob man ein bisschen mehr Fett mit dem Küchenbeil dazugeben würde.
Moment, was ist das? Fett?
Nee.
Frischkäse? Ich hab jetzt nicht zugehört.
Was ist das gewesen?
Nichts wie ein bisschen Creme-Cheese.
Creme-Cheese? Ah.
Ja, sowas, sowas, Frischkäse.
Das sieht gut genug aus, um es schon zu essen.
Die Sounds, die er immer dabei macht.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah.
Hey, jetzt.
Lass uns ein paar Sachen machen.
Burgers, right?
You've seen us do this a million times before.
Es muss klatschen.
Put your blessing on each burger.
Erstmal schön rein.
Just dimple it down.
You know why we do that, right?
And the peppers?
They've been roasted.
Char in the skin.
Awesome flavor.
Die Musik im Hintergrund.
Perfect.
Oh, yeah.
The beginnings of a Mexican fiesta.
All right, let's cook these burgers.
Now, we're gonna do it indirect, right?
We're not gonna do it direct over the flames.
This way we can control the heat.
We're gonna kind of do a reverse sear.
Indirect, opposite to hot coal.
Bake them for a little bit.
And now, the corn tortilla chips.
Ihh.
Äh.
Was ist das für eine eklige Pampe, Alter?
Ihh.
Slice up some onions, nice and thin.
And we'll clean these peppers.
You don't need the seeds.
They just give you indigestion anyway, right?
Mal gucken, was am Ende rauskommt.
That charred skin.
There's your flavor.
Yeah.
All right.
Now, like I said, we're doing kind of a reverse sear.
We cooked them partially first.
And now we're going direct for the flame
to get that texture we're after.
Der macht alles mit seinem Beil.
You kidding me?
All right.
It only takes a few minutes.
Ja, klar sind das Amis.
Also, mehr Ami kann man nicht sein wie der Channel.
Das ist Kokona pur.
I say these burgers are top.
Die Musik dabei.
Now, we're gonna take some more of that cream cheese
and spread it on top.
And why?
Because we can.
Again, it's adding another layer of flavor.
Woo.
Yeah, you know where we're going
with this, man.
Now, we're gonna take those
tequila-infused tortilla chips,
lay them on top.
Was?
Ich hab nicht zugehört.
Ich hab gegessen.
Ja, einen Löffel genommen?
Ernsthaft?
And we'll finish off the burgers.
This will get those
tortilla chips
Also, Löffel ist nicht erlaubt.
Oh, I get, I get, I get.
Hopefully you got some tequila left, right?
Dieses eingelegte Chipszeug,
das ist so eklig.
Now, we're gonna take some of our hot sauce, right?
And we're gonna add it to the mayo.
Again, this is the condiment.
You can set these up the way you want.
But this is how we're doing it.
Take those bells,
lay them on top.
Ich hab gedacht, die Dinger werden jetzt nochmal frittiert
oder irgendwas.
Aber die bleiben so lapperig auf dem Burger drauf.
Nee, das ist nix für mich.
Die meisten Sachen find ich ja geil
und würd ich auch mal gern machen, aber
das ist, glaub ich, nix für mich.
This is called pitmaster privilege here, man.
Add some more heat.
Place the bun on top.
And there it is.
Tequila, tortilla, chip burger.
Ich würd das Ding sofort futtern, ohne die Chips.
Gotta check this out.
Now, just because you're asking.
Okay, nächstes.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Ich brauch jetzt irgendwas.
Deep fried?
Was?
Nie?
Ach, NY, New York.
Okay.
Strip Steak.
Oh.
Hell yeah.
Ich versuch ja eigentlich dabei, was zu essen.
Was ist denn das?
Das Mayonnaise?
Was ist das?
PG.
And you got some bread.
And of course you got some oil.
Because we're gonna be doing some frying.
Alright, here we've got some New York Strip Steak.
And this is a great steak to use
for doing a deep fried sandwich.
It's very lean.
Not a lot of connective tissue
or fat in it to worry about.
Alright?
And what you wanna do is
get it fairly thin.
Maybe a quarter inch or so.
Alright?
You go 2,5.
If it's too thick, it might become too chewed.
Now, you can use your favorite cut of steak.
But make sure you get rid of that connective tissue there.
You don't want fat in that sandwich.
Or at least a bad one.
Oder hat man ein richtiges Messer?
Warum macht er das nicht mit seiner Machete?
Easy to do, right?
Now, we're gonna deep fry them.
So, you're gonna need some eggs.
So, take a few eggs, alright?
From your favorite chicken.
Leute, da ist ein Stück Schale drin, ich seh es.
Guckt.
And you whip them up.
Ich hab's gesehen.
Und bei meinem Glück bin ich derjenige, der das Ding mit Schale kriegt.
You've watched those cooking shows before,
where they show you how to fry.
But we're gonna do this again for you anyway.
Now, we're gonna season the eggs.
Alright?
Always wanna season the eggs, right?
And then we're gonna take those thin cuts of steak
and dredge them in flour.
Do it good.
Okay?
Okay.
Get them fully covered with flour.
Alright?
Perfect.
Coat them thick.
Excellent.
Now, what we wanna do after the steaks are floured, of course,
we're gonna put it into the egg.
Good.
And then into the panko.
Now, panko is oil-infused breadcrumb.
Makes a nice crispy fry.
You know all about that, right?
Now, if you don't have the panko, you can do more flour.
Panko is good.
Coat them well with the egg.
And cover well with the panko.
This is gonna be good.
Now, what you wanna do is deep fry.
And depending upon what oil you're using, of course,
use the instructions on your oil jug.
It'll tell you what temperature is optimal.
And it doesn't take long to do.
Now, remember, good steak is done at 130 degrees Fahrenheit and up.
So, cook them till the panko is just the way you want it.
Nice and crispy and brown.
That's usually good.
You wanna use...
I think there's a bit less fat.
There needs to be a bit more fat.
Read thermometer.
135 to 140 degrees would be perfect.
It won't take long.
Alright.
Now, let's toast up the bread a little bit.
Now, of course, if you've got some good steak rolls,
those steak rolls, go ahead and use it.
You just happen to have some white bread here.
And you just pan fry them up with a little bit of butter.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Good.
Man.
Now, we could have moved this a lot faster,
but we kinda like doing this, right?
Look at that.
First, put a steak sandwich in it.
We're doing that.
Bam.
Alright.
Now, you can set these up any way you want.
Here, the pit master's using a little bit of mustard.
If you don't like mustard, skip it.
I prefer to have a little bit of chub.
Alright.
Load on.
Couple of those little bit of butter.
Couple of those strip steaks right there.
Oh, Lord have mercy.
Ah, yes.
Can you smell that?
Smells good.
And if you can't, you're on the wrong damn channel now, aren't you?
What's that?
Oh.
Look at that.
Schmeckt wahrscheinlich wirklich gut.
Yeah!
Nice.
So, hat eigentlich, hat's Vodafone mittlerweile geschafft zu antworten, zeig ich mal her.
Ach ne, Moment, ich muss ja heute gucken.
Was?
Vodafone Beef?
Ne, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Ah, Vodafone Support ist auf Tauchstation, die haben keinen Bock mehr.
Die denken sich, fick dich, Max, scheiß aufstecken, wir scheißen da drauf.
Meinst du da arbeiten?
Ja, der Support ist 24, wir können das ja mal kurz überprüfen.
Ja, vor 43 Minuten.
Die sind am Start.
Die haben wahrscheinlich keinen Bock mehr auf meinen Gespammer, aber ich werde die jeden
Tag vollladen.
Ich werde die jeden Tag vollspammen.
Und umso mehr Leute mitmachen, das Ganze hier noch zu liken, retweeten und vor allem noch
sinnloses Zeugs drauf zu posten, umso besser.
Umso besser.
Dann kriegen die das nämlich mit, dass das auch viele Leute mitkriegen, dass es scheiße
läuft bei ihnen.
Na, das letzte, was sie geschrieben haben, ist, ich soll das Modem, das Modem neu starten.
Mal wieder.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie oft ich die letzten Tage mein Modem neu gestartet habe.
So.
Tja.
Ach, Leute, ich glaube, wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Wie wäre es mit einem Python-Bot mit Twitter, Arpi?
Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Sowas habe ich mir schon überlegt.
Ich glaube, wir machen jetzt Schluss, Leute.
Ich muss nämlich mal übelst dringend aufs Klo und ich muss dann auch mein Essen fertig
essen.
Das kriege ich gerade irgendwie nicht im Stream gescheit hin.
Außer wir gucken noch eine halbe Stunde Essen.
Wir gucken noch eine halbe Stunde Essens-Videos.
Haben sie das Gerät schon mal neu gestartet?
Oh ja, das kommt ja jedes Mal.
Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Stream, Leute.
Fragen sind nicht verloren.
Also, falls ich irgendwas heute nicht beantwortet habe, ist ja alles hier in meinem Stream-Mitlog-Tool
dabei.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream, Leute.
Macht's gut.
Bis dann.
Ciao.